and there have been some steps put in
place which Richard will go through um
to to address some of these challenges
and and to ensure that the service offer
improves so I'll hand over to
Richard thank you Nathan um so just by
way of introduction uh Trafford just for
members Trafford local Care Organization
is a partnership of the community
services that are provided by Manchester
University Foundation trust uh so it's a
community services here in Trafford for
children and adults and uh our adult
social care team which is led by Nathan
and this is one of our joint Endeavors
which is why we're both here uh today um
just want to apologize for not being
here in July unfortunately I had a
bereavement and couldn't attend but um I
think um members that have been here for
some time know that I always come to
talk up to my papers so I apologize for
that and I hope it won't happen again
for all sorts of reasons um okay so on
to the matters in hand uh so the paper
here that you have summarizes the action
taken to address the uh the backlog uh
customer service and the driving
capacity and the new it system which
we've put in place so what I'm going to
do is I'll split the presentation one to
talk about Community equipment and one
to talk about um AIDS and adaptations so
I'll talk about Community equipment
first um so uh the equipment to support
people living in the community is
commissioned jointly between uh Trafford
uh ICB and Trafford Council and it's
provided by Trafford local Care
Organization through a base and some and
about 20 um settings across Trafford um
it's provided free of charge and the
adaptation service of people living in
Trafford um is funded through the disab
disabled facilities Grant so if I talk
about the one stop to start off with so
um I think members would know that we've
had a very very old system in place
which um really was managed through a
series of spreadsheets um that made
provided equipment for Trafford so we
commissioned a new uh system um in the
beginning of the year uh and obviously
we did quite a long running um process
in terms of making sure it was fit for
purpose and implementation and it went
live in September and the difference
that it makes is a couple of sort of key
points for people really which is that
you can see
all the orders in real time around
individuals so people previously had
ordered five items which isn't uncommon
um to support them at home those would
have appeared separately on different
spreadsheets and um you'd be quite
shocked to hear that really but now
we've got a system so we can see all the
orders together the other thing which is
probably the most important is that um
when people order the equipment which is
um normally NHS staff but also social
Care staff as well they actually bought
the deliveries live with people so if
you're in hospital and you're arranging
to go home what we do now is that you
can we arrange with the with the family
or the individual themselves when they
would like to have the equipment
delivered so we can do that live whereas
previously what happened was that people
order the equipment and then there was a
delay whilst we arranged for the
delivery so both of those are
significant uh improvements from our
point of view um now um the other and
obviously then we've transferred all the
old we delivered all the old items that
were sat on the old system which is
called um kez 360 um so what I'll do now
is I'll talk you through if you look at
page top of Page Three uh these are the
actions that we've taken uh to date so
um we there were number of items that
were being delivered by the store which
could actually be delivered by the
community staff so these are foot
protectors in particular and also
cushions that the district nurses now
provide themselves and they keep a store
so these are things that would help
people obviously top right and to
protect their foot so they're like the
pots that people would would would have
at home um so now the staff are doing
that um we're changing the way the
driving is being delivered and we're
just working on that at the moment but
because of not wanting to have any
delays I've put in three extra staff for
six months on top of the ones that we
have currently to support the deliveries
that we're having uh in Trafford um and
then um the other thing I wanted to talk
about which is moving on to is about
customer service and I think you
probably all have had um local residents
that have been unhappy about not being
able to get through and find out what's
happening with the store and I know
that's been a significant issue so what
we've done is that we've put in an
additional member of Staff who just
answers the uh phones through to the
store and also the email so people
should be able to unless there's two
people ringing at once they'll be able
to speak to somebody directly and have
the emails answered as well I'm just
finishing off this week because some of
the phone lines that have been that are
publicized are old ones so with the
comm's team are just clearing the old
information lines numbers off the
website making sure the answer phones
are working properly so I've got
somebody answering the phones now um but
we're just shutting down the old lines
and arranging it so that should all be
in place for the beginning of next week
and I hope for our staff and also
members of the public uh that will be
very welcome because clearly if it's a
non-urgent item there may be a weit but
I think it's quite reasonable to know
what's happening with the order that
you've made so we've got that in place
as well now um and then also we've
extended the opening hours for the store
and the satellite stores which is where
we put the extra equipment uh we've got
social Care staff now being able to
refer straightforward items so that
might be things like a bath board or
something like that that people can just
arrange for themselves uh and then also
we've trained some of our Specialists
team so we've got staff who work in the
stroken neuro rehab team and the Pala
care team to undertake more complex
assessments so I think we've making good
progress with the store obviously I'm
very welcome if you want me to come back
and give you a further update in a
period of time because you've you not
all of those uh changes have sort of hit
the ground yet you can see that they're
in train so I was saying to the team
it's a bit like sort of watching the
marathon and getting to mile 23 and not
knowing who wins so I think might want
to me to come back and I'm very happy to
do that if you like because you've not
seen the the final results yet but we
are doing a huge amount of work on it um
colleagues um had some questions from
the July screws to be honest it was
probably because I wasn't there and
wasn't able to answer them um and you've
had those circulated and I've for
completeness we've set those out in the
report here uh as well so that you can
see the responses there so then I'll
move on to the second half of the report
which is page five which is the
occupation ational therapy assessment
team and there's two aspects to this so
these are the occupational therapists
who assess people for um AIDS and
adaptations and also then the staff that
um who then actually get them organized
and and procured as well so we had
similar issues with the other other old
it system that they were using and so
we've only recently now gone live with
um a new it system which is called emis
which is the rest ones the rest of our
community health staff went live with
this year uh and um that's in place now
we're just working on uh the data
quality for that because I think
colleagues if you work in an area where
you've got a new it system and obviously
when you switch it on there's quite a
lot of data issues that you need to sort
out so we're just doing that at the
moment and we've got Sally who's one of
our business intelligence leads Who's
down there at the moment just finishing
that offer us at the moment so that's in
place as well and then also we've also
fully recruited to the staff as well in
terms of the Run rate um we get um uh
we've got capacity for 170 cases a month
and we get 140 referrals so that um is
good news in the sense that we've got
enough capacity to be able to manage
that and we will be seeing the weights
go down we also did the uh assessments
that
um members here will know about in terms
of the extra work because during the
covid pandemic we um we um kept the Line
open but we stopped providing the
service which on reflection probably was
not the great idea um because people
just didn't make any difference to
Residents because they've just had to
wait anyway but uh We've caught up with
that now and we've completed those 800
assessments um oops sorry and then um so
the final thing now is that you can see
that um uh the case loads are reducing
um and sorry I'm looking at the wrong so
you can see now that um the weights um
we've now got a true and accurate
picture of the weights which is what
Nathan has referred to at the moment and
you've got that in the in the report and
I'm expecting team are now producing a
trajectory for me to show that that will
come down as we've planned and then
obviously the good news for the
adaptations team is that um whilst the
line was closed um they were able to
clear all the old cases so haven't got a
waiting list at all so I think to
summarize that kind of that's a summary
for me about where we've got to with
both the equipment and also with the
adaptations um but we're still not where
we want to be because of the stage we're
at at the project uh so I'm very happy
to take any questions that members would
have and also if you want me to return a
few month's time to give you a further
update on progress obviously I'll be
very happy to do so
thank you for that uh any
[Music]
questions councelor J Le hail counselor
um well first you'd like to say thank
you for all your hard work because I
think you've obviously come a long way
um and I actually speak as a recently
retired physiotherapist from another
burough who's came into health health
scrutiny has been really shocked at how
far behind it was here compared to
compared to where I was working it which
is another greater Manchester bough and
I could see how there are certain things
so for example the um the booking time
slots and that things like that will I
think will really improve things uh my
question though actually is around
Nathan probably won't be surprised to
hear this about round returning
equipment because I've had quite uh I'm
aware of two instances recently where
there been significant challenges to
actually get have people return
equipment uh so I'm be ke to know if
what targets you've got or what you what
sort of how if you've got a measure of
how much how much of a problem that
actually is and what what you're doing
to try and improve
that no thank you that's a that's a good
question actually we should have picked
that up in the report because it's an
important matter so thank you for the
prompt on that so we do um intend to
return or recycle the equipment which is
the point that I think you're you're
making but at the moment we've had
because of the driving capacity we've
had to concentrate on getting the
equipment out but we do know where
everything is and we're we're getting it
and I'm hoping that once we've got the
the rest of the drivers in we'll be able
to focus on doing that because that's
normally uh part of the job but you're
right to highlight I think that um for a
number of reasons um I think partly
because of the services here moving
between organizations on a number of
times that it was some way behind the
offer that was available in Manchester
and other places but we're catching up
quite quickly
now
[Music]
Council
heartley thank you chair and thank you
for the uh for the update and the report
uh and um you know it's really good to
see that the steps that have been taken
people have obviously worked hard to
address the the the sort of transitional
problems I think that the service had
after covid and um you know more staff
being recruited and um you know it's
clear we've moved on from that that
phase of of residents not getting
adaptations at all when fall in the line
I I had some I suppose I had some
challenges with the report in terms
of so
um I think chair for for us as a
committee one of the things that we need
to be able to do is to see the state of
a a service and the performance and
whether it's improving or not and what
measures we can look at to see whether
the performance is improving or not and
I apart from the fact that the service
is clearly in a better place than it was
I'm struggling to see the measures that
allow us to do that if you like um so on
page five of the report um there are
some figures
around waiting lists as in number of
people waiting so this is people waiting
for the occupational therapy assessment
isn't it so number of people waiting is
increased from
291 to
548 with the longest wait January 2023
so I guess we've got a couple of
question but I'll roll them together
that that longest wait January 2023 does
that mean somebody has been waiting
since January to have an assessment I'm
guessing that's probably what it means
and then I guess it's a little bit like
NHS waiting list I suppose isn't it
you've got how many people are on the
waiting list and then you've got how
long are they waiting um and I suppose
they're both measures you could look at
but for me a useful measure will be to
know how long are people waiting for the
equipment and is that improving or is
that getting worse
um so we've got demand of 140 referrals
a month this is to the the occupational
therapy assessment again and the
capacity for
170 um you know that's that's great but
there are 448 people waiting so just
trying to do the math but it will it
will take a few months to clear that
backlog of people waiting for assessment
so I don't know if you could help me
with that really as
to the waiting times for the
occupational therapist assessment so all
we've got on that is that somebody's
been waiting since January 2023 I think
and then what is the waiting time for
people to receive the equipment or
adaptations once that assessment has
happened thank
you okay thank you so um the the
difficulty we have at the moment is that
we're just working on the data quality
of of the new systems that have gone in
and producing the report so that Sal is
there at the moment doing that um I
could very happily either provide you
with the trajectory is through an update
report to circulate if that's useful um
or and or I couldn't come back and brief
you about about where we're going
because I think your questions are are
pertinent thank you I think the um if
you could come back with the report
uh perhaps not the next one but the one
after so that we've got some kind of
uh
right okay so if you could do it the
next one because you've got a new system
in place now and you should start seeing
improvements and you've got the the
Manpower so would that be happy with
that thank
[Music]
you thank you um congratulations on this
I've got ex colleagues that have seen it
in use and they're very um appreciative
of it so thank you very much um I think
councilor Harley beat me to the punch
with his question and um so I'm GNA do
my second question about training are
all the staff ready trained on this I
know you went live on the 18th or have
you still got a backlog of
training um to get through and my second
um the 800 of completed assessments via
the pro private provider have been
delivered so as that contract now ended
and you don't expect to use that private
provider um within the forceable so two
two two um important questions and thank
you for those so all the staff have been
trained I think it sounds as though if
you've work in in similar Services you
know that you train people and then when
they start to use it they can't remember
so we're doing we're doing backup
training for people as well uh which is
available we've got super users so yes
they have all been been trained um but I
think like all these things they um it
takes time to get used to it but we're
definitely offering that um support and
the other thing to mention actually is
that we had too many items on the
catalog to for them to choose some so
we've reviewed the catalogs and reduced
them down as well and that's been one of
the other things that we've been looking
at what we're starting in January is an
endtoend uh process for the teams
because we've kind of plugged in the old
system on the it system so we're going
to be reviewing that with all the stuff
and I'm involving them all we're just
finishing off plans for that at the
moment to make sure that all of that
works in the way that it should do so
the answer is yes but there's still
improvement work to to be done on that
and so in terms of the other assessment
so that was jointly procured by um
traffic Council and um mft um and we I
don't I can't see a circumstance under
whether we'd use them it's very unique
situation coming out of the pandemic we
like to consume our own
smoke thank you Council
eser yeah want if I ask another question
on um who does your minor adaptations do
you have inhouse staff that do that um
and again it's it's really around the
delay and then I'm interested as well in
sort of trusted assessors as well so you
didn't there is some reference to like
working with the neuro rehab teams but
there are a lot of community teams out
there who could be um just ordering grab
rails and staring
and then if they do that do they happen
very quickly or is there is there a
delay in that process so um that's part
of the the post Christmas phase because
I think what one of the things that's
very clear is that we we rely on the
store too much uh and I think that puts
in steps and delays for residents so the
other thing that we're doing is
broadening that out as part of the work
that I discussed and I'd like to see a
lot more um uh adult social care and
community health staff being able to
order and in some case have stores of
equipment where they work to be able to
get things out very quickly for people
and I've worked in teams um you know
when I was a practitioner where staff
did that and I think they did it very
well and actually enjoyed that aspect of
the work as well so it's we're quite you
know it's it's a as you've picking up
it's there's still improvement work to
do on it but you're absolutely right
those are things that we'll be doing as
well just a quick final question for me
then in terms of accountability of the
equipment
uh I think before the system perhaps
didn't have the full sort of view of
everything that you may have not had
returned or and now you will have we can
see all the equipment in Trafford on
that's on the system so we've also got
pieces that were ordered and are in
place before this new system was put in
and we are in the middle of of loading
that up onto the new it system so we
will be able to see where everything is
so my that line in our action plan that
I've set out with Carrie says no
spreadsheets that's the title of it
thank you much and we'll look forward to
the the next report then uh just whilst
the meeting's been on I think we've had
three people coming could they perhaps
just introduce themselves so we know
there apologies it's Alison Jones
okay and
was okay
there I'm Council Tony O Brien from
Ashton on Mery Ward okay and
then
Dr apologies for being late I
was thank
you okay thank you
uh so can we approve that report thank
you thank
you we now have uh item six which is the
dental access children's friendly family
scheme
Trafford and we have uh Mr Squire thank
you very
much um uh
so colleagues will have received a
report around dental access and
initiatives in traford um I'll take the
report as read but there's a number of
matters that i' would look to highlight
um uh and particularly around the focus
around uh Children's Dental access and
Children's Services um so I uh I did
report
to committee approximately a year ago um
which included uh reports on uh post
pandemic uh position of dental services
and dental access um recognizing the
impact that the the covid pandemic had
on dental services and the recovering
position that we had then we continue to
recover there's still an impact on on
overall um dental services but our
access position you know is showing
strong recovery um on page 11 of the
pack you'll see the position for
Trafford where by at the end of March
this year we had recovered back to a
comparable position of March 2021 and
that that that recovery continues
through um in this year as part of local
commissioning we've uh introduced an
initiative around um Dental access
incentivizing local practices to see new
patients not just existing patients in
order to address some of the access
challenges that we have across great to
Manchester and in her Trafford 20 of our
practices out of the 34 have committed
to that to that scheme to see on a
regular basis new new patients and uh
that that is having an impact at the
moment um over five and a half thousand
new patients have been seen in Trafford
since since April um in
October those practices saw over a
thousand P new patients just in that
month um however I I will mention that
even with the demand Fair NHS Dental
Services we're still um experiencing
failures to attend from members of the
public so these really you know valued
services that are in high demand um in
October there there was um over 600
appointments in Trafford that were were
failures to attend that uh was access
lost to me members of the local
community having said that though um
Trafford does continue to to to increase
um access for uh for local patients and
uh particularly draw attention to page
13 of the report where we can see the
position for children accessing a cross
greater Manchester and Trafford has some
of
the best position for for children's
access
um and particularly recognizing The
increased position over in comparison to
the past couple of years so uh almost
70% of our our children in Trafford have
been able to access an NHS dentist um
obviously we would hope to see that
continue to in increase um ideally we
would hope to see all children H have
that
access and what I would highlight is
that even though that's a very positive
position it does mask variation in
Trafford and uh and the position of
children's oral health in Trafford is a
varied position
although Trafford has some of the best
children's oral health in in great
Manchester we know
that there's inequity particularly
between North and South Trafford and as
as a recognition of that we're working
with um the public health department in
the local Authority around oral health
Improvement and some focused in
interventions around uh children's uh
support for supervised toothbrushing
access to uh fluide tooth toothpaste um
and uh as part of that looking at how we
can encourage children's access into NHS
Dental Services part as part of our
access initiative um however I would
highlight that even when children have
access to NHS Dental Services if they
have significant treatment needs then
often that requires an onward referral
to Specialist Care that's provided um
either through the Children's Hospital
at M Manchester Foundation trust um
through the Dental Hospital in
Manchester or or through Bridgewater uh
Community Dental Services and we know uh
we know that we uh following the
pandemic and previous prior to the
pandemic there's extremely long waits
for some of those Children's Dental
Services um in the specialist
Services part of the response to that is
using traford General Hospital surgical
site as a surgical Hub to provide
additional capacity for great Manchester
in order to address some of the the long
longest weights so that so that's
something that's very um convenient for
for Trafford but is supporting um across
the whole of the great Manchester system
our challenge around um increasing that
capacity is not the availability of
dental Workforce but pediatric
anesthetic Consultants um which which is
a challenge to the wider system um but
we continue to work on that on that
situation as part of our general Dental
Services response to uh to uh children's
access and Children Services we have
developed a child-friendly dental
practice that's referred to in the pack
um which uh provides some enhanced
Primary Care uh support and service in
order to seek to prevent children having
to go to hospital or being subject to
general anesthetic uh procedures um
where possible unfortunately despite
seeking to engage local provider in
Trafford that there hasn't been a
practice that's felt in a position to
respond to that um but we did we do
ensure that um children who require that
are able to access those Services um in
Sur surrounding localities in Salford
and in Manchester but uh we we have had
a significant development in Trafford
whereby at alteram at the alteram Hub we
have developed a Dental training Hub
working with the uh Dental Deery for the
Northwest which is part of our uh NHS um
Workforce Development program that that
hub is almost ready to open its doors
and will be supporting postgraduate
Dental training and wider Dental Dental
uh Workforce Development so uh therapist
training Dental nurses training and we
would hope that having that that's um
center of excellence in Trafford will
support further engagement with our
local dental providers and attract
additional dental providers and so we we
are confident that we will be able to
EST establish not only child-friendly
dental practice service within the
within the buau but also look at other
Innovative opportunities around
dentistry and oral health
Improvement I'll I'll leave it there but
happy to take any comments and feedback
thank
you thank you for that um is any
questions counc
ler thank you I've got two questions
actually one was just for me to
clarification really um where dentists
have got contracted number of udas are
they paid for those if they don't
achieve them that's one of my questions
okay so the technicalities of the
National
dental
e
thank you councelor
Harley sorry uh asford
sorry um yeah I was I just wondered
about the obviously enormous cost of
going to dentist puts people off and I
wondered how if people are aware of the
support they can get if they're on the
low if they're on a low income um I also
didn't couldn't find anything there
about the struggle to find sorry the
struggle to find an NHS dentist don't
know whether that's included in there
because OB very difficult to find NHS
dentist now and um just the enormous you
know still there enormous disparity
really in dental care for example you
know a dental implant cost 3,000 which
is obious beyond the capacity of most
people and so people you know to suffer
through not having teeth and not being
able to eat properly so it is really
concerning
so so the um the uh the costs of NHS
Dental Services um as colleagues will be
aware unlike um the majority of NHS
provision yeah which is free at the
point of Service delivery a general
statement that's made around the NHS for
dental services um unless an individual
is exempt patient charges there is a
charge that charge has increased over
recent years it's nationally directed
it's not something we have any control
over um and so it's now in you
know well in excess of 360 pounds um but
for any individual who is exempt that
then that that conversation would
generally take place with the with the
dental provider um and advice and
guidance is available either through the
NHS website I know healthwatch
colleagues support um Clarity on on
those matters as well um what what I
would say is with regards to the implant
costs
um there are only three charges for NHS
Dental Services um and an implant if it
was provided would fall under the ban
three charge the highest charge but that
is not
3,000 3,000 is the cost of an
independent or private implant provision
um uh implants um if they're clinically
necessary would be available on the on
the NHS through through a dental
practice but by and large um
alternatives to implants um are provided
so crown and Bridge um ra rather than an
implant um so so it's quite difficult uh
I I could I'm not a clinician I wouldn't
be able to advise on clinical decision
making of that nature but the uh the the
dental charges are very very explicit
and laid down and there are only the
three charges in respect to finding a
dentist then uh we we do regularly seek
to provide um information out to the
public um and uh three colleagues around
finding a dentist which and that
information is available on the NHS do
UK website part of the access initiative
is the commitment to update that that
website to ensure that if a practice is
engaging with the access program that
they are advertising that they make that
they're available for new patients
unfortunately you know if a practice is
receives lots of inquiries then they
have to work through those inquiries so
they may not be able to see a new
patient um as quickly as one would hope
but there is that commitment to continue
to see new patients thank you can I just
sorry can I just follow something up I
mean I'm aware that most NH you know the
dent does provide information about um
applying for for the I can't what it's
called now the the the support they get
on if they're on a low income but it is
very off-putting because people think I
can't go to dentist because I don't have
any money so that that my biggest
concern really yeah yeah and sorry can I
just mention we are aware that with the
cost of living crisis that um a number
of people aren't ex does don't fall
under the exemption criteria but the
charges that are levied for for NHS
dental services are still a challenge
for them so so we recognize that that is
still a difficult decision and a
difficult determination for individuals
um but unfortunately it is a nationally
a national regulatory
position the application of NHS Dental
charges thank you Council Taylor
please thank you very much for your
report
um would you be able to just explain the
data that you've provided in figures one
and two about udas what that means and
the figures and if quoted the figures
for Trafford and how they um score
against GM scores but I don't quite
understand that data can you just
explain that to me and the the sort of
inferences from that data as well
please certainly so as I mentioned
earlier on um Dental contracts are
12month contract they delivered through
through the course of that those 12
months and so figure one presents the
percentage of that 12month contract
delivered as at the end of September
yeah so after the first six months of
the how much what percentage of the year
contract has been delivered at that
point so recognizing that there's a lag
in the system so H the reporting will
always be slightly behind one would one
would generally expect that to be if
everything was timely to be 50% so end
of September halfway through the year um
and Trafford practices at that point had
delivered 37.8% now recogn ing that lag
that's not
not a terrible position to be in
particularly if we look at greater
Manchester
39.2% um there are other areas of
Greater Manchester that slightly better
better more has been delivered some
slight slightly worse um and as great
Manchester the figure two We compare cre
to Manchester's position with other
areas of the country and actually
our dental services in Greater
Manchester are delivering you know we
see greater Manchester fourth in the
country as an ICB which is you know is
considered to be a positive position
what I will
say in terms of figure two is um that
that's as a percentage of the contracted
activity whether or not that contracted
activity is sufficient for the local
population is a separate consideration
and I yeah I couldn't comment on other
areas with regards to that thank you
that is really helpful and would you say
that it's anticipated that all of those
contracted due days would be delivered
by the end of the year or is that not
possible to say that probably
interesting to have that data to to see
how yeah how if they have been delivered
through the year won't it what I would
say is that um that delivery is
significantly better this year than it
was last year so we and that's part of
that recovery post pandemic position
that I mentioned earlier on um the
current indication is that we will have
a you know a reasonable outturn by the
end of the year what we're currently
monitoring is that uh a recognition that
those practices that are engaged in the
access initiative are actually and
seeing new patients are actually at risk
of over uh overperforming delivery more
than their annual contract basis and so
we're we're just reviewing that to
ensure that we effectively don't don't
run out of access by The End by the end
of the year okay thank you can I just
sneak one other question chair please um
in the report you've highlighted there
are 34 practices in
Trafford is it possible to say are they
distributed equally AC I the 22 Wards or
sort of districts within the borough are
they are those practices sort of
distributed evenly across the Bor do you
think all residents
have equal e access to practices or the
concentrated in particular parts of
Trafford the there is a General
Distribution um what I would say is
probably the north of the Bor has
slightly less distribution and
unfortunately that's often the inverse
care law U because these are long long
established practices and there's not
often the opport to commission new um
practices um but there's a relatively
good distribution across across
Trafford the greatest challenge is that
actually those practices and those
contracts are variable in size and so
that that is more of the challenge not
just around proximity but around whe the
balance
of service service capacity for the
local population um and on that basis
uh again I would say that again probably
there's less overall capacity um in some
of our more deprived parts of the buau I
would recognize that but as I say that
that's part of um where we're looking at
how we can work to address some of that
through oral health Improvement
initiatives as well as working with
those local practices to increase
capacity and
responsiveness well thank you I think
that's really important isn't it you
know because you as you highlight in the
report later on you know dental health
is a indicator of global more widespread
Health isn't it really you know and I
know access to dric is only one part of
having good oral health but it's it's a
it's a strong Factor isn't it in
supporting people to maintain their oral
health and also that you know you talked
about cardiovascular risk and things
like that don't you
so which goes down hand in hand with you
know greater deprivation and areas of
poverty so it there's definitely a
connection there isn't
there absolutely and what I would
highlight um I'm not sure if colleagues
have uh received um a copy of the
greater Manchester Primary Care
blueprint which is our strategic
document across greater Manchester as
how we are looking to develop um and
deliver primary care services including
Dentistry over the next five years but
that highlights Health inequalities it
highlights exactly those those matters
and um how you know the focus and
commitment to to access and
collaborative working to to address just
those those matters no thank you thanks
CH thank you councelor
py thank you chair um on page 29 figure
eight a map of practices signed up to
the GM Dental quality access scheme um I
I've gone through through and I just is
there any chance of getting a list of
those individually in
Trafford um because they're not I can't
see the list in there somewhere um and
the second part um the Deery in I think
it was
1819 it may be 19 into
20 um was uh concerned about managing to
get new dentists qualified in time for
the retirement bubble and and I just you
probably don't know um I just wondered
if they fed in with any long long-term
projections about filling one vacancies
and two retirement specific vacancies uh
that we may have and may require over
the coming
years thank you um yeah I C I can
certainly look to provide that that list
um what I would say is again if um
colleagues look
the nhs.uk website I can pretty much
guarantee that any pra local practice
that is appearing is accepting new
patients on that website is one of those
practices um we here we have um
something like 5% of dental practices
across the country and last time I
checked we were providing more than 20%
of the
country's practices that we offering
access for new patients so so so yeah
yeah checking on the website would
basically bring up the those practices
what the map shows is the distribution
um of that um in terms of the workforce
challenge that continues to be a
challenge um for two reasons one is that
um although we have dentists qualifying
new dentists
qualifying part of the challenge is um
the commitment to the NHS for for the
people coming out of dental school um
unfortunately there's a real culture of
um you know a negative attitude towards
working for the NHS compared to
independent or private business and we
have um colleagues working with our
dental school particularly in uh
Manchester um to seek to change that
culture and that perception um also what
something that I'm currently working
with the Deery on is um increasing the
use of dental therapists where it's
appropriate within the scope of practice
because under the general Dental councel
therapists are able to um prescribe
treatment uh and undertake in their own
uh CES of treatment without um the super
direct supervision of a dentist um and
but some of that does require um
additional prescribing such as uh an
local anesthetic Etc so so we're
currently working with the Deery and
some of our local D Dental leads around
how we can increase our Workforce
through some of that work as
well thank can I ask you um question on
when the dentist practice is established
or what kind of control or power do you
have over them into certain extent I
mean is it possible if they established
said yes you know you got to provide a
certain percentage for
NHS uh service before they're given
permission or license or some however
they set up new practices okay so
there's there's no um control that we
have and no powers that we have to seek
to en enforce either a qualifi newly
qualified dentist to undertake NHS
Services um or or um to control if if a
practice chooses to establish itself to
have any any NHS commitment that so so
so it is it is limited the here the the
governance over the provision of dental
services and the quality uh um oversight
of that does sit with the Care Quality
commission Dental all Dental practices
are required to be registered with the
CQC whether whether they're an NHS
provider of services or provide
independent services but there's uh but
there's no
directive to enforce commitment to the
NHS I'm
afraid I think
Dentistry sorry um Dentistry has been uh
a major uh factor in health watch is
work both locally and nationally um and
particularly since uh the uh
pandemic um and in fact we gave evidence
to the select committee uh which is
sitting and looking at industry um and
we're awaiting their uh report at the
moment uh I think one of the things that
does concern me and we have discussed
that and we've got meetings set up to
take it forward but it's about uh access
really because we know at the moment
that each day the uh 1111 service
receives 150 calls a day about dentistry
and it's about looking uh for a dentist
so it is a
communication uh um problem that really
needs to be um addressed now we know
about the number of calls because it
comes to something about 48,000 a year
but what we don't know is that having
been given some advice whether in fact
they then subsequently are able uh to
get hold of a dentist and um I might
have the figure wrong I don't know and
I'm sure that Ben will tell me if I have
but um in the uh the general population
only about 30 or 40% of people are
registered with a dentist so you know
it's a really crucial area and as was
pointed out um a lot of the um uh the
cancers um that um arise um they can be
um either identified through a dental
examination H and people can get earlier
treatment and so you know everybody
really um you know it's just so such an
important area um that I think that you
know we need to keep her a weather eye
on really thanks thank you for that and
I believe there's patient feedback
Health watch so engagement Now isn't
there between the local dental committee
and the health watch Representatives as
a reporting mechanism maybe you know
those kind of things will be brought up
and something you know more substantial
can be established in terms of getting
more NHS work
done thank you for that report um
counc heartley um just just one area I'd
like to ask about May chair so
um I mean I agree actually with with
what Heather's just said just to say I
think I think um you know I know from my
own experience that access to Dental
Care is vital in terms of spotting
cancers amongst uh adults and children
actually um and I think
um I mean I think for me poverty I think
is the main factor that affects dental
health and I think that goes to
councelor axford's point about access to
NHS Dentistry um but I think I think
locally the report does does highlight
some really good initiatives to address
Health inequalities so you know this the
um the info around dementia uh friendly
Dentistry is really interesting uh
looked after children um as well um Ju
Just I just wanted to pick up on I think
councelor leester raised the point about
um uh the Asylum Seeker pathway um and
how
we do we do have bridging accommodation
in Trafford for people seeking Asylum uh
and so obviously it's whether those
people will get picked up but uh but
what we also have in Trafford is we have
hotels and other accommodation that used
as as bridging or temporary
accommodation for people who've recently
been homeless and I just wondered
whether there is any Outreach work going
on
to uh to provide Dental Care to to
people who are who are either homeless
or recently being homeless Anda thank
you so we don't have a current
initiative explicitly around uh the
homeless um it is it is a real challenge
Dental access per se is a challenge and
then we we have a number of you know
priority um cohorts of patients um we've
mentioned cancer patients we mentioned
the Asylum Seekers you
know children's Etc and it is very
difficult to to be able to prioritize
everybody that we would hope to So So
currently no there's not um a a specific
um piece of work around that however um
more than happy to work with you know
local colleagues around uh to see what
what support could be made available
available um for anything of that
nature thank you for that and uh thank
you for the the report and it's for
noting so can I approve that thank
you can I ask a question yeah
sure just for my information what are
the provisions for out of hour dental
services for
[Music]
weend
so for out of hours we do have um an an
Urgent Dental Care Service uh that's
available in the evenings and at
weekends it's not 24 hours uh 247 um
it's available 10 o'clock at night um in
the evenings um and that's based on um
National guidance around urgency because
uh it's rare that a dental condition is
actually life-threatening uh so it's
about being able to provide seek to
provide that response within um within
24 hours so if someone did phone at 10
o'clock at night um they would look to
be offered an appointment the following
morning but also given um pain pain
relief advice and to manage the their
situation um during that
period so and and that provision we have
that we have um a center uh within
traffic that that provides that we
have that out out of ours provision in
each of the 10 localities in great
Manchester and it's accessed through the
Urgent Dental Care help helpl line and
and the details are uh in the pack in
terms of your your second question sorry
just could you just repeat
that so yeah so so the CQC um in
inspects approximately 10% of dental
practices each year um but also will
respond to any referral or you know
concern that's raised it's it's unlike
um General Medical Services General
Medical Services um the CQC inspection
outcome is one of five statuses
effectively you know outstanding good
which meets standards um requires
Improvement or inadequate uh for dental
practices they either meet meet meet the
regulatory standards or they don't meet
the regulatory standards and by and
large we very very rarely um have
practices through referred to us by the
CQC for not meeting those standards
there may be areas that they could
improve and we work with those practices
to address those
areas and I approved
uh you can leave if you want to now if
you
got
oh CER it's not a question for you so
you'll be glad you'll be able to go it
was just um on the comment that
councelor uh Harley made that um uh
Public Health are actually doing a piece
of work and it was information that went
to Children's SC scrutiny this month and
they're actually doing some work with um
uh families in resettlement hotels and
in homeless accommodation around oral
hygiene and uh providing toothbrushes
and toothpaste so I think that's the one
way that we can get in to start
supporting some of our homeless um
residents across the Bor thank you thank
you
Council um okay so now item seven
elective procedures and performance
update so we have the associate director
for delivery and transformation Trafford
Kathy
Risco thank you chair um just like uh
Ben said previously I'll take it as red
the document so what we prepared here is
um a slide deck which updates on the
performance of elective recovery and
we've made it very specific to Trafford
so you can see what that looks like I
thought it was really important though
to bring back what the governance is
that's sitting around the elective
recovery program and I'm sure you can
see from the slid so if you wouldn't
mind if I just talk through them very
briefly just to give an overview um the
GM elective recovery program is very
much led by GM so it's not Lo at a
locality level and on slide three in
your pack you'll see the reporting
structure so again it's the GM
integrated care board the trust provider
collaborative which is on the trust
provider collaborative that's
representation at an exact level from
each accruit acute trust across
GM um and then they are six pillars
which sit beneath that um which are in
slide three in the excuse me the blue
boxes um and in on Slide five you'll see
in a little bit more detail about what
that what those each of those pillars um
do and their key aims and Ambitions
about children young people integrated
elective care surgical hubs within that
there is a GM team that sits in each of
those pillars and each of the the acut
trusts on um a fortnightly basis feed
into each of those work streams where
they give their Assurance for the
delivery of wasting list management the
delivery of surgical H the utilization
of the independent sector so from a GM
level they are getting the Assurance
from an acute perspective about elective
recovery but not just elective recovery
is in the numbers of patients having
their elective procedures delivered but
about all those support mechanisms that
do need to be in placed about making
sure and monitoring the wait waiting
list making sure that we um that GM have
an overview so I'm making just giving an
example so if Bolton have um capacity
within the
um oral surgery services but we know
that there's a peak demand across um the
Manchester footprint in relation to
Manchester Foundation trust the GM team
are working to see where they can um
contact patients and move them so that
they can hopefully get through those
elective procedures in a more timely
fashion I'm sure you might have seen in
the local press as well that um Trafford
General is one of those elective Hub
sites um that's obviously very effective
so they are in place across the whole of
Greater Manchester so it was just to
give you an overview of the governance
that is sitting over that elective
recovery program and in the other slide
deck it gives the Trafford position for
elective care um and waiting procedures
I'm sure you can see we are now in a
position where we have decreased in
regards to the Trafford weights and you
can see that as a comparator um to the
elective weights from from a GM
perspective as well feedback from our GM
colleagues has been very much that um
due to the the doctor strikes and all
the consultant strikes as well that has
significantly impacted on elective
recovery but as you can see from the
trajectories here we are going in the
right direction when it comes
specifically to the weight so that was
just an overview and a summary obviously
more than happy to take um any questions
thank
you councilor
py thank you um
I it may have been cided and obviously I
I was under the assumption
that um a 65 plus pillar was going to be
created
to to focus in on that getting them in
and getting them discharged safely um
even though there may be other pillars
so I'm assuming that was not decided as
right so they said no we don't need that
I do have other questions as well oh
sorry sorry that's fine but you can
answer that one first write them down go
um
the someone that's actually gone through
this elective pathway this year um I was
cancelled because of strikes so I
understand the the precious you're under
yeah
um do we have the the full waiting list
across greater Manchester and in
particular um mancher Foundation trust
trust for
elective but also elective from urgent
so people that have come in um through
A&E yeah have been semi- treated or
primarily treated but then require that
elective treatment to happen following
that and the weight time they're having
um because that was me and and I i' I
was actually quite shocked at the speed
at which I got seen and followed through
so I want to know if that's consistent
or if people are waiting longer than I
did uh in that case um and that's it
don't worry thank you
um just on the 65 plus pillar um this
information is from the GM team as of
last week sorry in preparation from the
papers we're ready so it's a couple of
weeks so I will go back to them and see
if there's been any further developments
on that 65 plus apologies I can't answer
the question but I will bring the
information back and we have so much
data as I'm sure you can imagine in
relation to um elective weights and what
I didn't want to do is go into too much
detail here but obviously we can bring
that as back as another agenda item if
you would like that very specific
information or I can send that you to
you directly um about where we are from
an mft footprint but specifically on the
coming as an Emergen as an urgent and
then have an elective procedure I'm not
quite sure whether they record in that
way because the the coding system is
slightly different I don't think it
necessarily would but I'll obviously
again I'll go back and speak to our bi
colleagues and see what information and
data we can collect so it's a bit more
meaningful
thank you uh councilor
Gilbert and thanks for the report and
for kind of outlining some of the
actions that are being taken um I've got
a I've got a few questions so um the
first one is just I um only joined this
Committee in 2021 so what I don't have
is the kind of context for preco
obviously when I look at those charts I
think that's alarming but uh what does
good look like is my question kind of
what did it look like beforehand good um
uh it's really useful to have the
Trafford and the Manchester Benchmark I
just wondered do you know any other
benchmarks around the country kind of
how do we compare to Scotland or Sur or
anywhere like that you know uh are we
you know H is Manchester well served I
guess is my question um and I guess it's
really good to see the governance around
it and it's great that you outlin the
hubs so we can see that there's some
action taken and I obviously I
understand how you'll have been held
back back with the doctor strikes I just
wondered if there's any forecasts or is
that almost impossible to forecast at
the moment when you might bring into
kind of a more desirable number of
people within those great times so sorry
quite no that that's fine thank you all
really really good points obviously um
completely understand about the pre-co
so you can actually have that
comparative and that analysis and I
think this was just like a start of a 10
really because it was the first time
it's been asked for so if we do another
Suite of data obviously we'll have that
compar so we did that all for the Urgent
Care review and all those types of
things so it's a really good point I'll
make sure that that happens for next
time um and then again about how we
compare to London boughs Etc from a
Manchester perspective we do have that
data um I know that our GM colleagues do
so I'll ask them for that and I can put
that in and for each of the um for each
of the acute trust there is a trajectory
of of the reduction in those waiting
list so again I can provide that
information so we can see how where
those trajectories are and how they are
in line or not the case may be and
through the impact of things we've
described so again lots more data that
we can provide and will do obviously so
apologies it wasn't in there this time
but it's quite hard to know what
everybody wants so this was just a start
for 10 million we'll move it forward
from there thank
you thank you councilor
Taylor thank you for the report um
obviously there are a still a
significant number of of really high
waiters of 78 weeks plus
um two questions um what do you and I
know that's it's not unique to traffic
by any means um a what do you attribute
those those really long weights to and B
is there anything anything to sort of
mitigate those weights for those people
you know are they being offered anything
as an interim kind of management or
because I'd imagine if you've waited 78
weeks for surgery you know that you
probably experiencing some quite
significant problems and discomfort and
limitation as a result of those so two
questions there please thank you thank
you again once really good one really
good questions again so in regards to
the 78 plus week weights obviously if
you look at the Trafford position I know
the numbers are quite small relatively
specifically for traffic there's a lot
of people collectively across GM who are
on those so um when if we refer back to
the pillars so in the pillars things
like wasting list management so making
that people are being supported by
access to additional information and um
providing them with information where
they can get additional support services
for while they wait for those procedures
is one of the pillars um that they're
doing I know that GM colleagues are
doing a that yeah they're doing a lot of
work on that to make sure we know it's a
a
significant
not very clearly sorry apologies is
making reference to for those very
specific conditions whether there are
slots that are becoming available where
there's a lower there's more capacity in
different areas so patients are being
off a choice about changing to different
locations so hopefully that number will
go down a lot quicker than we're
currently seeing at the
moment thank you Council Bo it's just on
the back of that um I know specialist
nurses are filling that waiting list the
waiting time period with advice and
guidance um I know this is probably a
very difficult ask what I'm about to say
um is there any success
Matrix that they're feeding
into to act so we know that they're
getting through to people they're able
to communicate with people at home
people are picking up the phone and
answering them um and are being prepped
well
um to towards their procedure or or
their appointments or yeah that that was
just an addition onto that because I
just drugged into my mind there yeah um
I don't know the detail that would sit
behind that I'd have to look into that
little bit more again extremely valid
questions and I think it's something
that we would hope is happening but we
need to make sure that that is is
actually the case and I think if you've
been on one waist for 78 weeks you might
have forgotten what happened at preop or
anything else that's required so I'm I
know I don't know the the level of
detail but in those pillars I know that
the waiting list management and the
supports patients whilst they're on
those waiting list is one of the key
things that they're focusing on
especially after um recovery from the
strikes and covid Etc so um I'll I'll
look into it a little bit more detail
and go back for further clarification
from GM colleagues
thank you Council
Lester thank you um I was just referring
back to the earlier paper actually
around equipment and adaptations and I
just wondered if there's because
obviously there have been a lot of
delays with that whether that's having
any impact on this well because either
be for people actually having the
procedures in the first place or
certainly safe discharges home which if
if it can't be safe someone can't be
safely discharged home that might mean
that somebody else is canceled because
there's not a bed available and but and
obviously we faced a lot of challenges
with that so and I just wondered if we
sort of have any sense of how how much
impact that's having and if we're sort
of trying to Le leas between those
Services really to minimize the impact
of delays with equipment and adaptations
there's been a lot of work done in
relation to ensuring that patients
discharges are coinciding with the
appropriate um equipment that's been
made available and you would hope with
the length of some of these potential
weights that there all that planning is
done and put in place um and certainly
know from our um discharge working
really closely with our control room Etc
that that is all part of the process so
I don't see there's any correlation at
the moment between discharges being
delayed as a consequence of equipment
Etc there's always going to be the odd
nuances but the the services seem to be
working extremely well now obviously
within the REM of the control room so I
think it's become quite seamless we
don't see that there's a natural
correlation between that but um I'm sure
if we if you get any feedback on that
we'll be happy to pick it up
thank you for that so it seems like
there is a
bit Council Lloyd
um yeah you've mentioned discharges
there's obviously um a will to get the
other people elective surgery um to be
seen um
treated um but also you have winter
pressures in hospital which are all year
round um
what's discharging people um how how
many people have to come back into
hospital because perhaps they haven't
got the support that they need or
they've been discharged too
quickly that's a really wide question um
it is a wide question but I'm
asking I'm asking the question because
it's has been at
this and by a member of the public um
about early discharges and there's
obviously pressure within the Sy there's
pressures within your system and it's
good that you're trying to reduce the
waiting list that's great but it's the
people that get home afterwards um are
they been discharged uh from hospital uh
more quickly um and have they got that
support when they're there and I have
actually um
um you I know you have been passed on
one complaint that I've had as well so
it's is concerning about whether people
have being discharged too quickly from
hospital if I may councelor light I'll
I'll just um add to to what um Kathy was
outlining in in terms of um failed
discharges it is a metrics and it is
something we collect um so I can't quote
anything
right now in the meeting but can
certainly provide some some details
afterwards um and a lot of the
initiatives um which you referred to
actually in in the winter plan uh item
which we're going to discuss later such
as the Back to Basics program are all
about trying to mitigate those sort of
instances from occurring and putting in
place good practice to to support um a
really safe and effective discharge but
happy to to provide some figures to the
commit
outside the meeting thank you because I
think it's something that um we should
be looking at as well although I do
congratulate you on trying to reduce the
waiting list it's not very easy for
people who've been on the waiting list
concerned about their health as well
which it actually imp impacts on their
mental health as well um so um it does
need to speed up and get get people done
okay thank
you
clearly there's some concern around the
figures at the moment um but it is a
very much a a juggling act as well yeah
and uh so we thank you for that report I
mean it's it has sort demystified a part
of what is somewhat complex and
sprawling structure so I think the the
charts were quite good in explaining
where everything so sits so to speak so
thank you for that report uh can we
approve that
report thank
you uh so uh now we have the item eight
which is the Health social care winter
plans
and thanks I'm gonna give Kathy a rest
andon introduce this one few comments
for me and then I'm gonna hand over to
Nathan who's gonna take the second part
of the report so okay thank you uh for
the opportunity to talk about this yes
so we've shared a very short summary
paper but there is a huge amount of
detail in the winter plan which will be
published in December which we can share
with the minutes will bring back to a
future meeting and that detailed plan
will include you know the plans for
Christmas and New Year bank holidays as
well quite specifically so that's you
quite an important document which we
developed in collaboration with
Manchester colleagues and the governance
around that it's through the Manchester
and Trafford Urgent Care board and
there's been a lot of scrutiny to to
develop that plan this year working with
GM colleagues as well um so so I just
wanted to touch on the
funding because it's an issue issue that
we deal with every year and quite often
we get fairly late notification of the
funding so so for this financial year
and for this winter we were notified
quite early on in the financial year of
what the funding for additional capacity
would be for each locality so the amount
did change and so for additional
capacity for Trafford we were notified
of 1.7 million pounds so so that was
back in I think it was in the summer we
first notified of that so we've been
working with Partners across Manchester
and Trafford and more specifically in
Trafford with all of the partners
through the locality board to agree what
would give the biggest impact both
against the key metrics which we have to
deliver against in terms of urg
emergency care but also for the Trafford
resident so so we were really clear
through those discussions that it was
really important to to support as much
of the system as we could even though it
was a relatively small amount of money
me 1.7 might sound a lot but it's not
when you start to look at all the
partners working in collaboration so so
last month I think it was the locality
board agreed a plan to utilize 1.7
million and that was a real sort of
Blended approach for for additional
capacity in general practice for
supporting mental health throughout the
winter you know because we know mental
health patients being stuck in acute
hospitals in particular is a real issue
but also to provide some continued
funding for the acute escalation Beds
which have been open pretty much
throughout the year um so so they were
the three areas which we prioritize and
we're now in mobilization phase so only
in the last few days we've agreed the
schemes with the general practice
colleagues through the general practice
board I'm in Trafford so so some really
exciting schemes which will bring a a
significant number of more appointments
throughout that four month period from
the 1st of December through to the end
of March so over and above that we heard
probably only a few weeks ago that you
there was an additional some of money
SO2 million pound for GM to support
primary care so so we are expecting a
further
130,000 pound for surge activity for a
surge Hub in each of the localities so
so the first trans to that funding will
be received in December I think that
we've submitted our plans for that with
partners
today um you so that will go live also
in December to support you know even
more activity through general practice
you for those that really need it um
during those four months so so so I'm
not pretending it isn't going to be a
really challenged winter you because it
is every year and we know that that will
hit hard you for a lot of uh partners
and patients but you but I think you
we've done the right thing and trying to
support as much of the system as we
can with that limited resource
so so the third pot of money was I'm
going to ask Nathan to come in so so we
had an opportunity as well to bid for
additional local Authority support
funding so for the second page section
four of the report you
describes the additional work that we're
going to do because we were successful
and in that bid and received a further
440,000 pound so Nathan's gonna talk to
those bids a bit more detail thank you
thanks kth yeah so the um £440,000 um
this was awarded to us um and it's
important to note that the um the
invitations for bids were um ring fenced
for authorities um that were in an ICB
system either in tier one or tier two
intervention so all of Greater
Manchester have got a slice of of the
money um the trafford's um contribution
we've looked
to really um support discharges as per
the the kind of requirement but also the
the the other facet of the requirement
was to prevent um reduce our delay um
the need for for people to to receive um
support especially in emergency
departments so though we had very short
turnaround time I think we had two and a
half weeks
to because of the good systems we've got
in place in traffic so have General
conversation with a range of Partners so
the first intervention on payens to
users this is people who've been
identified and our colleagues at mft
know who the individuals are who
regularly with emergency department and
for a multitude of reasons but quite
often not medical reasons um so the the
model is a national model something we
haven't had in the living before which
is effectively having um a trained coach
who will work with the individual to
provide that sort of support understand
what their issues are um whether they be
social issues Financial issues mental
health issues and work with them linking
into some of the community office um and
trying to divert them away from that um
that setting and that principle is
something that um feeds into the second
um Intervention which is the the test
and Lear extension so this is something
that the prim Care Network
um networks I should
sayle to look at build from some of the
work that done in the summer in s West
around engagement with people
you wouldn't ordinarily be in touch with
family care or any kind of Heth services
and lot the the interactions were
Community settings so they going into
the food bank or into other kind of
things that going on in the S West
Community Center and they actually found
um about 150 people um managed to Ste to
some basic health checks and various
other things um and in some instances
into local
GP were picking
up
rks this all falls within the BHS
ambition of the 20 plus 5 which is to
look at
20% communities then to focus in on the
five
areas of
priority um ground hypertension stroke
and
list remember maternity steal
illness disease cancer diagnosis so um
by targeting people who by nature don't
access
a um in terms of the the rapid EDT
program I think again really important
this
one what coun saying right Pathways this
is making sure that we are supporting
people to go home where we can um
pathway three um is basically put people
into long-term care so can um through a
multidisiplinary approach and getting in
very early in the discharge process we
can triage people that found the pilot
about 40% of people could potentially be
diverted into their over home with
support which is clearly a better
outcome for them and financially forth
as um and the support for br bridge and
the the analyst support is all to to
help facilitate some's really important
often back function so really welcome
brand um we get money on Monday
um so the challenge is to really make
some
tra we've tried to
pick thank you uh any questions on that
Council
P Terri it's always me
um Nathan under the
440,000 the expansion of the rapid MDT
pilot I I know
um working on something very similar
about 10 years ago in 2013 I think as
part of surgical pathway um one of the
problems we had back then was um access
to GPS because the communication lines
between discharge and that information
getting to the GP that that patient's
been discharged uh was too long and and
we I know it suffered at the time so I'm
assuming this pilot will take that into
account so GPS know when their patients
have been discharged home within 48 72
hours yeah that's
fine and my second
question is over that way um when I find
this
oh I know the acurity beds um have been
used all year and I've been gone through
many Winters
and my My worry is that these acurity
beds are already in
[Music]
use where's the Overflow to those
accuracy
beds is there a an Emergency plan in
place for that
scenario if they all get filled up
really quickly which let's be honest we
think they will um is there something
else on top of that just to keep some
wiggle room in the
system so Kathy might have some thoughts
as well but I mean I agree with you you
know it's huge concern that there is
beds not all of the beds so not so much
of the beds that the traffic residents
are accessing but certainly the north of
the patch of Manchester in particular
then you is a huge concern because those
beds are being open pretty much
throughout from last winter all the way
through to now so so so the hospital is
very high occupancy as you know so so
that is a real concern as we go into
winter so as Nathan said the combination
of trying to to
only agree ad missions you know that are
really required is the first part of
that and to try and treat as many people
outside of hospital to avoid that
admission is a first SP but then also
the number of people that we're
discharging now and Nathan talked about
this previously around this table is far
higher than we've ever done before so
that that flow is there but but I think
it's probably a key risk as we go into
the well you seen the weather today as
well you know you know as we move into
the winter it is it is a huge concern um
so no contingency as such other than the
schemes we're putting in you know in the
the winter planning process we got
anything else
yeah just to add that just give a little
bit of context as well so I completely
share your concerns but just to note as
well that the within Shore um winter
beds were stood down during the summer
period so that is the pressures are more
in the North Manchester Hospital than
they are an MRI then it is particularly
in Trafford but it's still a pressure
don't get me wrong um but just give some
context for the additional funding
that's coming into primary care so as
Gareth made reference to it's about
trying to put more capacity in the
prevention element and also we've got
the Trafford crisis response service
which has been absolutely exceptional
and we're seeing probably about 40 to 50
patients per week on that so that is
supporting patients who are potentially
at risk of readmission or an admission
into hospital with some acute conditions
that are Now supported by a specialist
nursing team in the community so that's
now in place and running really
effectively but also for the additional
monies that have come for winter for
Primary Care specifically that's an
additional 15,000 appointments of face
Toof face same day urgent appointments
that will be made available during
winter and also um a surge harbers G GTH
made reference to that will be open
seven days a week and potentially
another 5,000 um 5,700 appointments
available so hopefully with that
additional capacity we've got within
primary care and that urgent access
that's available it hopefully might
mitigate some of that flow thank
you thanks I was just going to add part
of that 1.7 million that we've used I've
said that's for for continued funding
that is specifically for traffic
patients in with andore which have been
closed but we are standing them up now
so that's our contingency I guess but
but I share your concerns I think we all
do Council
Lester um I just wondered about um covid
and where we're at with that because
obviously it's sort of become I'm
assuming now it's now an endemic
condition and whether we're expecting
any sort of Rises or impacts of the
numbers of that which obviously would
impact on our winter winter pressures if
that if that might
happen so so I know a couple of months
ago talking to the director of Public
Health it was a concern that you know
that was starting to to you to make a
comeback as it were I think from the
various escalation calls I've been on in
the last and we go every week to a to a
GM escalation call on a Wednesday that
hasn't been an issue that's been raised
so so I'm not suggesting it's not a
factor and it couldn't come back at any
time and we know that don't but that
seems not to be the key you know a key
concern at the moment for our provider
colleagues thank you counc Taylor
think I was just gonna um make a little
comment to Nathan particular done
amazingly well to secure that nearly
half million pounds there and it's going
to have to work very very hard isn't it
that money really you're going to do a
lot with it I just think and I think the
initiatives are fantastic you know
things like the test and learn and you
know cing people in nonclinical settings
really to try and um get them to
consider the health sort of before it
becomes becomes you know an urgence or
an emergency situation I just wonder if
it' be possible to have some feedback
maybe sort of later you know perhaps in
March you know as to the outcomes of
those initiatives really and uh you know
some examples of some some good practice
really certainly and I I think the
challenge is of course getting hitting
the ground running and for December is
always um interesting but in terms of
the the formal reporting mechanisms for
the grant are actually in February and
May so we have to do our full evaluation
to government on the 31st or 30th of May
I think it is um so happy to report back
yeah maybe if you could share that with
us that would be we'd like to know that
yeah thank
you Council was just in addition to
council lesters a point and I I probably
it's probably come into my inbox already
um but do we know where the vaccination
rates are for Trafford in terms of uh
influenza and um covid uptake so
far what coming through through our
senior leadership team two weeks ago
with that detail so Kathy can try and
access it now but I haven't got the
numbers in front of me but for the covid
vaccination booster we're doing well
again
comparatively um across GM for the flu I
haven't got those numbers um I haven't
got those with me I don't know if we can
find them but but we can certainly share
them did you
yeah is that the flu Jam go
[Music]
there I think that's the co jobs isn't
it I've
got
this is
co right I think we'll share them
separately I think yeah we've already
got the covid ones yeah thank
you okay just one quick uh question
these uh acute hubs are they de where
they're going to be or
uh not yet no for the program this yes
so the acute surge hubs um for the are
going to is going to be delivered from
traford General site by our M call Who
deliver our urgent treatment center and
out of hours
provision do you mean the for the U the
funds you've got you for the acute
respiratory infection hubs yes oh sorry
I should have made that more explicit
apologies so um we can give the update
so for acute respiratory infection and
also for same day emergency access that
will be delivered by every single GP
practice in Trafford and also supported
by um Master call um who are are out of
ours provider and also deliv the urgent
treatment center at the chaffer general
site so we've got complete
um sorry a complete spread across every
single Trafford practice that we'll be
offering those on a daily basis and if a
practice some practices obviously don't
open on a Saturday or Sunday then that
provision is covered by our colleagues
um of Master call here will be open
seven days a week so we'll have full
coverage throughout Trafford starting
that will very tense about the 4th of
December but all those Services starting
on the 4th of December so that will be
delivered um hopefully extremely
successfully thank you for that it uh
looks like a very promising project that
and I'm sure the residents will be
pleased that and reassured that uh
they've got that support actually
especially with the kind of weather
we're having lately as
well can we approve that report thank
thank
you so we now have the item nine which
is the uh cancer diagnosis one and we
have the director of Public Health
Allison Jones here
yeah hi there sorry I'm trying to spare
people my coughing um so I'm presenting
on behalf of Helen viin director public
health so I'm Lucy R speci register on
public health and Allison's colleague
from GM um so I believe a paper came to
the committee earlier this year um
describing PC rates in Partington and
some recommendations uh for Action so uh
the paper that you've seen for this
committee is a progress update on those
uh interventions and a lot of activity
going on which um I I'll summarize um I
think just quick recap um in terms of
the background to the initial paper that
came earlier this year um in 2019 a GP
at Partington Central practice um
approach director of Public Health uh
perceived that they were seeing higher
rates of councel than they would uh
expect uh Public Health England as they
were at the time uh asked the the
National Cancer registry to uh review
cancer rates and pars to have a look at
the data uh the data available at the
time was 2010
2017 um and uh just to say now the
office Health Improvement and
disparities they're rerunning that
analysis currently we're expecting that
in the new year with the data running up
to
2021 I guess the the key messages from
that is that uh yeah cancer rates uh are
higher in in Partington than the
Trafford and England averages um but the
profile is typical for deprived areas
like um Partington uh so it's not an
outlier in that respect uh lung cancer
is the most common cancer there um so
the work I'm going to uh discuss a lot
of the work is focusing around sort of
lung cancer prevention and early
detection um GP data so quality and
outcomes framework data C data um again
par and family practice uh cancer
prevalence no higher there than the
Trafford average slightly higher at um
the central practice but but only
slightly um the big difference to
highlight and I suppose to take home
message for us in terms of inequalities
um the differences in cancer mortality
so people dying from cancer rather than
getting cancer in the first place that's
the issue um and while this is sort of
population level data so it's it's it's
Trends and patterns overall uh it's not
going to tell us the precise reasons for
these differences um it's reasonable to
expect that the reason we get
differences in cancer mortality uh is a
factor of how and when Cancer's detected
uh the stage of disease when it's
diagnosed um and treatment that people
receive when and where um so that was
the the background to the paper and I
said the analysis is being rerun at the
moment just to to have a look at that
and to check as I said that again yes
rates are high but as we would expect
for an area like
Partington lots of detail in the the
paper and in the paper earli this year
about the sort of wider determinance of
health and huge range of factors that
can influence cancer rates um but key
risk factors smoking alcohol obesity
physical
inactivity um but I thought for the uh
purposes of today I'd focus on the sort
of cancer specific work and particularly
in Parton in some smaller projects but
Alison if I hand over to you now just to
give the of GM context and I'll come
back to the specifics
afterwards
piece oh no it's working sorry I've got
it sorry apologies for that so I'm
Alison Jones I lead on commissioning and
early diagnosis for the greater
Manchester cancer Alliance so the cancer
Alliance is one of 21 cancer alliances
nationally and cancer alliances tend to
act as the cancer arm of the integrated
care board in the new structure so we're
very much part of the greater Manchester
integrated care board leading on that
work on cancer
a significant part of my role is early
diagnosis and locality engagement so
those two go together really really well
I think in the context of the
conversation this evening so just to
pick out a few key projects that the
alliance are leading on but very much
doing this in conjunction with
colleagues in the 10 localities
including
Trafford so we do a lot with our Primary
Care networks so there's already been
referenced to Primary Care networks in
the conversation this evening we have 65
in Greater Manchester and each of those
65 we have a named at least one named
cancer lead so we've got somebody we can
go directly to to provide that support
around that early diagnosis and early
acknowledgement of
cancer we do that by providing
colleagues in primary care with a
significant amount of Education giving
them the tools and the processes that
they need to be able to refer patients
quickly when there are signs and
symptoms that could indicate cancer we
also do a lot of work on the public and
patient facing community Communications
so that people understand what to look
out for and understand when to present
their GP with something that might be a
sign or symptom of cancer we work a lot
on the uptake of the screening program
so I know in the paper that you've got
for this evening there's reference in
there to the three cancer screening
programs and the position in Trafford so
we do a lot of work to help our
colleagues in primary care and in local
community organizations with that
screening uptake we've actually invested
funding this year as a cancer Alliance
in activities in the Trafford locality
to do that so working with colleagues in
the locality providing some resource to
enable that engagement activity around
screening uptake and early
presentation we have had um a prostate
cancer case finding project which is
probably a good example so prostate
cancer incidences one in four black men
are likely to have cancer one in eight
men are likely to have prostate cancer
so we've done some real really targeted
education and engagement during the
summer this year we did have a rather
brightly colored turquoise and yellow
van which people may have seen all over
the Press so that did visit locations in
Trafford people were invited to go there
via text messages from their GP if they
were in that at risk category they were
given a PSA test if the PSA test was
positive they were then taken through
some of those Pathways so it was a
really well structured and quite
targeted project to try and bring out
that early diagnosis message around
prostate cancer and that was something
that was active in Trafford and actually
I think Trafford had quite a significant
proportion of the activity as well given
the population breakdown so that was a
really positive project I think for
Trafford we're also running a targeted
long health checks um program it's been
in operation in Manchester for a number
of years we've also had a targeted long
health check project in Salford in
tamide we're now rolling this out across
the whole of great Manchester it is
going to transition to be a formal
screening program so there will be a
lung cancer screening program and the
targeted lung health check work is going
to transfer into that the way we're
rolling this out is using a risk
stratified approach so looking at lung
cancer
mortality and looking at smoking rates
and um lung cancer incident and
deprivation where priority izing the PCN
areas across greater Manchester and
taking the long health check project out
starting with the areas of highest
likely incidents so that we're getting
to those patients who are more likely to
have a high incident of lung cancer
first so given the reference that's
already been made to the incident of
lung cancer in Trafford the data that
we've got will actually put the Trafford
PCN in that process and in that priority
with all the other PCN in Greater
Manchester um just picking up on a
couple of things very quickly the system
work that we do we've got um a number of
pathway boards which colleagues from the
Trafford locality are involved in you've
got a very active GP in the Trafford
locality who works with us a lot on the
early diagnosis work so she's one of our
GP leads for early cancer diagnosis and
all of this work is designed to support
the achievement of a National Standard
whereby we need to reach 75% stage 1 and
two diagnosis of cancer by
2028 so 2028 sounds like a long time
away we're currently in Greater
Manchester at around
54% so we've got quite a way to go to
get to 75% but that's not when you were
asking before about the comparison with
other areas it's really not far off the
England average so we're not on outlier
from that perspective we do have some
quite significant variation across
greater Manchester and I would say
Trafford is one of the localities that's
performing well against that when you
Benchmark it against the other nine
localities in GM but given that we we've
got to get to
75% within the next now four and a half
years we have some way to go and because
of that we have got an early diagnosis
program board which is leading this work
across GM with that locality
input um so I'll start with the lung
health checks actually so mentioned that
lung cancer is the most common cancer in
Partington um and uh smoking is likely
to be attributable to that um so smoking
prevalence in Partington is 14 and a
half percent that's compared to 8% in
Trafford as a whole so much higher
smoking prevalence in Partington and um
lung cancer about 70% of cases of lung
cancer are directly attributed to to
smoking so seems likely that the higher
rates we see in Partington are going to
be partly at g to high rates of smoking
so we've got a a Bor wide smoking
cessation program that stop smoking
service but targeted work in in
Partington so blue sky their Center in
Partington I'm doing um some specific
work uh for people with uh serious
mental illness um so 35% of people with
serious mental illness in Trafford smoke
so much much higher than the burough
average so supporting those people uh to
quit in terms of the lung health checks
program that Allison mentioned
Partington Family Practice is the first
practice in Trafford um to be selected
to to start rolling out that that
program of work it actually began at at
the beginning of this month um and uh
paron Family Practice are inviting uh 55
to 74 year olds uh to a weekly
respiratory Clinic uh 55 74 year olds
with a history of smoking uh have a risk
assessment uh and then further uh
onwards U referral for um investigation
if needed uh and that's for uh lung
cancer but also for other lung disease
um so that started um again Alison
mentioned work to improve uh uptake and
coverage of uh three current national
cancer screening program survical breast
and bow um a voluntary sector
organization called BHA black health
agency uh commissioned earlier this year
to do some work in Partington to support
women to attend their SM test to try and
improve uptake uh of survical screening
that replicates some work that's quite
long-standing in the north part of
Trafford uh that voice of BME another
voluntary sector organization carry out
um again calling patients who haven't
attended uh haven't responded to
invitations to screening and supporting
them to to come in um just a couple of
last bits in terms of activity to draw
people's attention to uh a project
that's due to start imminently uh is a
community engagement project called
through the front door um that's in West
and Central and that's with the uh one
of the patient participation groups um
and that is around uh people with lived
experience of cancer working in their
communities often at a very hyper local
level to increase people's knowledge and
awareness of Science and symptoms of
cancer so again as Al Sim saying one of
the the issues around late presentation
late diagnosis potential is that people
don't know what to look out for so that
that project's due to start
imminently uh and then the final thing
I'll mention um is a population Health
Fellowship so uh we're the only local
Authority in the Northwest who have a
population Health Fellowship it's an NH
England program um our fellow joined us
in September he works three days a week
at a GP practice in uh in sale but the
two days a week he's with us he's going
to be well he is doing a research
project around cancer in party
and it's a community engagement focused
project um working with local residents
again understanding uh potential
barriers to accessing care coming
forward presenting um and going to the
GP when they've got signs and symptoms
so yeah that's just a flavor of what's
what's going on in part in particularly
but across the bureau as
well thank you councilor
Bo this is a brilliant piece of work by
the way congratulations putting it all
together
um I just want to ask a question about
cervical screening um I know cross great
to Manchester over the past 12 to 18
months there has been a quite shocking
rise in STDs that have been reported and
the prevailance of super goner
um I know that we we're only screening
25 you know 25 is the lower age limit as
defined by nice is that yeah um are we
actually can we create something that
creates Sexual Health alongside the SME
the cervical screening test as well to
try and get because we know when people
are getting
STI it can lead to a cervical
in um problems and issues in the future
anyway so can we work with our Sexual
Health Partners and and uh colleagues to
try and uh create something that does
two jobs in one that's my question yeah
I can pick that up um so most um
comprehensive STI screening just take
place in specialist Sexual Health
Services but we do have screening as
well in Primary Care primarily for
clidia and gorea with the focus
particularly on on young people often
for women under 25 um but yet we
encourage um sample takers um people who
undertak smar to use that opportunity
you know for opportunistic screening
there um but yeah I think there probably
is scope for more joining up there um
but yeah it tends to sit as a separate
thing in terms of that comprehensive
screen but clid and gonor yes in primary
care I I only say that because I know
the you have the um the breast screening
uh portable you know uh truck Lorry that
you comes around and I think if there
was some way of actually doing this
because we know
and I think you've got it here in black
and white deprived areas have higher
instances of cancer of STI of lower
Health you as a whole and if we you know
if we can try and focus some kind of
Walkin coming get everything tested you
know a full body
holistic um health check um in one go I
think it just ticks a lot of boxes there
um especially in more deprived areas
thanks
sorry Council
heartley thank you chair um sorry can
can I
stop did you want to come back on that
or did uh um I would again just to say
that we've done a lot of work to try and
improve opportunistic screening and
opportunities for again particularly
young people um to to get screened um
for STI and clid and Gara um people can
order kits online for for home testing
we've got um home testing kits available
at at GP reception desks at Talk Shop
our young people Sexual Health Service
at s water side but again I appreciate
that it's that sort of Outreach
sometimes into those particularly
deprived Aries can be more
challenging Council
heartley thank you uh I think counc
counc might want to comment on that on
that question so I'm happy to okay thank
you thanks very much um Council har um
yeah um on that point um we had an event
in um Trafford just recently it was
around GM um Women's Health and Trafford
have also got um some events around uh
Women's Health and um Dame Leslie Regan
was there she's the Ambassador for uh
women's health she's the first
Ambassador that has ever been appointed
for Women's Health and what's going to
come from that is it's going to be a
woman's health Hub in every every one of
the 10 um boras so that Health um
Woman's Health h will be able to address
all W women's issues in one in one place
so we're looking forward to that um
Coming online and very soon so it will
pick up and I think that what what I've
heard and I'm not 100% sure but it's
going to be sort of like towards Al
Trafford I think it might be we're going
to be looking at the Limelight somebody
was saying in GM to me that it may be
that we're looking at Limelight for this
hub for women to be able to go and have
anot
[Music]
do you pleas thank you chair um yeah
yeah I think the report's really good
there's some really useful information
in the report so so thank you I can
remember the original report made from
uh it made for really um depressing
sobering reading I think um about the
cancer rates being higher but also uh
residents in Pon being diagnosed later
so therefore survival rates being worse
um and you know the report sets out some
really good work uh addressing heal
Health inequalities uh although the main
issue again I'd highlight is poverty but
clearly we're dealing with the you know
the the the effects and the impacts of
poverty um so well I had two questions
I'll roll them together um one one is
about um uh screening and health checks
so it follows on a little bit about what
canel lorei uh asked um which is that
certainly for some of the screening it
looks like they're effective when they
are accessed and
accessible I suppose so there's there
sort of talk there's the this this van
can around um the um which think is for
prostate screening and then um I think
we talked last time about the breast
screening unit coming to Partington and
and I think that's really important um
because because Partington is a it's an
area of deprivation
and I don't know if it's encouraging but
it's it's maybe comforting to know it's
not significantly different to other
areas of deprivation but it is also an
area that's that's inaccessible um and
so I do think uh as Ken lore said having
that sort of accessibility of screening
programs is really important so I wonder
um so I had a question in particular
about the health checks um and sort of
anecdotally there seems to be sort of
mixed evidence about whether they're
really effective um although it sounds
like they are being effective here in
terms of the referrals that we're going
on I don't know if the report sort of
says what the takeout rates are for the
health checks in Partington as compared
to other areas of Trafford or nationally
and is is there any evidence that in an
area of deprivation like Partington that
health checks can be more effective
because of the you know acute health
problems that that you that we see there
and then sorry my second question was
just about the two GP practices in
Partington so on some of the measures
this what looks like quite significant
differences between the two practices
and I haven't checked whether there's
always one practice that appears better
than the other and I'm sort of being
careful what I say here but I just
wonder is there anything in that is
there anything significant in that
between the two practices that um that
explained those those differences thank
you um so up your first point um so with
regards to screening and accessibility I
think that's a huge issue and we know
it's a barrier to take up and like you
say part waston as well as being an area
of deoration is geographically isolated
and difficult to get in and out of and I
think historically particularly with
breast screening the fact that they
didn't have the mobile unit there women
Wen able to get amrs locally was was a
problem and but work has been done this
year and we're really pleased with we've
had that confirmed in the last month or
so that we've got the site secured uh so
the next round in Partington is uh
November of next year so this time next
year women from those two practices will
be called and the unit will be on site
in Partington so that's great and
actually just to say in the north again
an area where uptake of breast screening
is lower the um mobile unit usually goes
in at seam old Grove I think from what I
understand that's not ideal I think
parking can be quite difficult it's
challenging for women in other parts of
the north to get to literally this week
in conversations with emirat Old
Trafford and L Cricket Foundation uh and
the um program Le for the Manchester
breast screening program which covers
Trafford is going out this week for a
site visit with a view to potentially
having the mobile screaming unit moved
there so again I think in terms of
Transport links the visibility of that
venue I really hop that could be
promising so watch this space on that
one um in terms of health checks um I'd
have to go and have a look at the data
just in more detail with regards to to
that I suppose we're saying that NHS
health checks is primarily a program to
prevent or pick up early cardiovascular
disease but with that you will get
people with risk factors for cancer as
well like like smoking for example so
people when they go for their health
check if they are a smoker have a brief
intervention with their GP or practice
nurse they can be referred for um
smoking cation support there but it's
it's not primarily a cancer prevention
program it's a CBD prevention program um
but yeah I can I can go and look at that
in terms of the differences between the
two practices again you do see
differences but again it tends to be
very small numbers so you can get those
fluctuations and actually those can Ur
by chance they not necessarily statistic
significant if you look at them side by
side but again something that we can go
and have a look at in more detail but
yeah Council chot thank Qui question
just eching on previous questions um you
doing a very good job thank you but you
mentioned that you're targeting from sa
one and two detection of cancer for 54
person and aspiration is to be at 75
prac but your timeline is up to 28 2028
that seems quite far what's the Val for
you to do that sooner and why not
2025 and yes you're saying that the
comparable data compared to that rest of
England is we are a far why can't we be
better why can't be the center of
excellence why can't Beed Shining
Light so it's a national standard the
75% so that's not a standard that has
been set by JM cancer Alliance that's a
National Standard it has been for a
number of years I would love to get
there sooner um so we are doing a huge
amount
of you can I carry on what are the
barriers that you expect or
anticipate so the barriers are variation
so you look across the 10 localities of
Greater Manchester and there's
significant variation that's a barrier
but it's also an opportunity because we
know where those big challenges are
another of the challenges is engaging
population in coming forward with signs
and symptoms of cancer I think we tend
to focus a lot on screening uptake but
actually if you look at the figures that
are provided nationally and when you
look at them at a GM level the
proportion of early stage diagnoses of
cancer that you get from a screening
program yeah that's great but actually
the higher proportion will be from that
symptomatic presentation so we're
focusing a lot on sending information
out there so that patients know when to
come forward they know what signs and
symptoms to look for we've broken that
data down so that we can identify the
specific cancer types where it's a
particular issue so I think we've got
nearly 90% of our breast cancers in
Greg's Manchester diagnosed at stage one
and
two you look at lung cancer you look at
lower GI cctl bowel cancer that's down
in the low 40s so we need to challenge
some of those specific cancer types as
well and it's engaging a huge population
across greater Manchester from the
public
perspective and 420 odd GP surgeries in
this as well so for me the trick is
working with groups like this with
colleagues in each of the localities who
know the communities who know the
populations who can get the messages out
there because for me a huge I wouldn't
say it's a barrier I do think it's an
opportunity that Community engagement
part of it is an essential part whether
that's getting people to take up offers
that are made or present with symptoms
you might describe it as a barrier but I
think it is a real opportunity if we can
crack that
yeah you're not only saving lives you're
ring complications you're improving
quality of yep so as long as you're able
to send this message
across and I don't think the are doing
that very well
okay
a I think we would always be open to
suggestions as to how we can do that
better either at a GM level or a
locality level working with colleagues
in localities always Keen to find out
the Trafford project that was referred
to before the through the front door
project that was a project that was
presented to the cancer Alliance and it
was one of only five that were funded
because it was so obvious that it was a
great thing to do so we had 56
applications for that funding we
approved five and one of them was that
Trafford project it's brilliant and I'm
sure the finding that we'll get from
that we'll then pick up and encourage
everybody else across GM to do it so any
ideas that we get from localities we
will pick
up thank you and no doubt we'll be
getting further updates on this
uh yeah it's du to start of the New Year
through the front door if not this month
if not December so oh it has oh great um
so yeah we can we can
provide Council
Lester thank you yeah I remember the
original report as well so it's really
good to see all the work that's being
done and very much appreciate it think
my question might sound a little bit bar
humbug but um the uh so one of the issue
the previous report was that the breast
mobile breast screening had been stopped
in Partington and hadn't exit been there
for quite a while and and I can imagine
there's a lot of work gone behind this
to bring it back um it just seems a
shame that it's not for another year
that it's actually going to be there so
it's a bit disappointing having said
that I recognize the word that's
probably gone into actually getting it
there so so breast screening is a as a
program is a bit different in terms of
how women are called so unlike survical
screening when you're called every three
years according to your birthday um
breast screening women are called by GP
practice so the practices are called
once every three years so the van's not
there at the moment but Partington women
aren't being called for breast cancer
screening at the moment if that makes
sense so they were last called two years
ago when the van wasn't there they'll
next be called in November 2024 when the
van will be there which is great so it's
not like anybody's missing out on at the
moment it's just that those invitations
go out three yearly by practice
years
yeah Council P just on the back of that
um I know um in sorry I think it is that
was the model I was looking at when
people move into an area that has just
had that that system happen instead of
them waiting
three years because they may not have
had a screen for three years
previously um they I think they're being
fed in to um the next site along um is
that happening in Trafford by the way it
should be so it's part of national
screening quality assurance standards
that you have fail saves because exactly
that point the women who move practices
if you just happen to join that practice
when they were called last week you
could potentially miss out for three
years so I understand there are fail say
some mechanisms in Place those practice
lists are submitted periodically to the
National Breast screening programs to
pick up those women who might fall
through so yeah that's M
standard Council brand do you wanted no
okay thank you I just wanted
to sorry
sorry please one of the standout figures
in this report is that bucko St Martins
and nobody's mentioned it uh deaths from
lung cancer um you know is this not an
example of where we should be
concentrating our efforts and having
some sort of a deep dive because I
assume it's related to deprivation or to
high rates of smoking and and drinking
but it's a really stand out
figure yeah I I agree it is um smoking
is one of five priorities on the health
and wellbeing Bo there's been that deep
dive process as part of that but exactly
that with book close Martins and all the
work in Partington it is targeted at
things like smoking sensation the lung
health checks for example through the
front door because of that high
mortality from lung cancer but agree
some of that is that wider determinant
stuff and related to to deprivation more
generally as well as being smoking
related
yeah my final question actually was just
around that a little bit just I mean I
know Partington is often cited as the
most deprived area in the bur and yet
you know look look at the the cancers
within smoking and alcohol I mean it's
quite an expensive habit really isn't it
and you wonder how they manage
to um you know support that significant
amount of the income must be spent on
that and uh you would think that it must
be having a knock and effect on the
health and wellbe mental health and
wellbeing of it the wider family so of
you know if that's the case so I mean I
suppose the important thing is form of
this prevention is obviously better than
the Cure uh and maybe it's it's a hidden
in many
cases from family members as well to a
certain extent so I'm just wondering
whether there's perhaps more
stakeholders that could be involved and
engaged within this prevention area
possibly other government agencies you
know that uh or voluntary sector that
that could be so engaged that that could
come up with a much more let's say
promising route rather than we just sort
of still trying to find ways of
prevention and uh educating people uh so
I'm just wondering whether there's
perhaps some opportunity to to look at
again at some of those other
stakeholders perhaps not just look from
a
more NHS or the the Health Service side
of
things yeah so um people will be aware
of the um government white paper
recently stopping the start so a huge um
National program um to try and eradicate
smoking within a generation but as part
of that work which has come from the
chief medical officer all localities
have been given additional grant funding
to support their work around smoking
sensation um and prevention work uh so
preventing children and young people
from starting smoking in the first place
and supporting those who do smoke uh to
quit so we've the public health team has
has received that Grant and that's
boosting our local um support offer but
again always very open to different ways
of working um you smoking prevalence has
come down hugely in my lifetime 30 40%
but remains really stubbornly high in
certain groups particularly people with
serious mental illness and people living
in the most deprived areas and it's
that's you know that's the hard nut to
crack and again it's these Community
engagement projects for example an
example of that sort of hyper local work
um that might be something that can can
move the St for us yeah I I think
to uh looking abroad you know on the
content that there's it seems to be a
lot more smoking and drinking and you
see people you know that's it's
significantly more than you see them
here as my own personal experience I've
seen but uh yeah so you wouldn't say
something yeah the formal targeted long
health check program that is the huge
fans that drive around with the CT
scanners and things on them they have
smoking sensation advisors on there as
well so you go in there you have your
long health check conversation if you're
deemed high risk you have a CT scan
there and then and if you are a smoker
you will have somebody who will have
that conversation with you there and
then when you've been told that you need
a CT scan or you've been told that
you're really high risk you will also
have somebody speak to you about smoking
sensation and actually give a
prescription for nrt if that's decided
what's needed so it's really that sort
of teachable moment whil you've got
somebody on a big van being put through
a CT scanner being checked out for
potential lung cancer it's it's a core
part of that offer for a long health
check that sounds good great yeah okay
so can we approve that report excellent
report it was thank
you uh and now we move on to the
item okay uh item 10 the IVF treatment
update and we have H Kathy on that one
was it um thank you very much chair and
I promise this will be the last time
you're here for me tonight um just
wanted to give an overview of the um
assisted conception policy I'm sure
you've all read the paper um it gives an
overview that it pardon sorry it
confirms that the um there isn't a
locality GM assisted conception policy
all GM localities follow one assisted
conception policy the only change
in relation to any of those localities
is in the number of cycles that are
offered and I'm sure you've seen in the
paper that Trafford is with the majority
of GM localities that offer one cycle it
was also to give some assurance that
there's been a slight change in the um
prior approvals process um so the
beginning of this year on the 1 of July
TW sorry of last year
2022 previous to that you used to have
to get prior approval from GM to go
forward with um the the IVF policy but
now that's been removed and therefore
what that means is from um a GP who sees
um a couple who would like to go forward
with the IVF if they believe as per the
policy guidance that they fulfill the
requirements to have that referral made
the GP can simply make that referral on
behalf of the um the the people who are
requesting it so that's the main summary
of the paper but also just to give
assurance that um I'm sure you're
probably aware for some people people in
the room that Trafford used to offer
more than one cycle um and just to give
Assurance I think it was in
2017 I will confirm the date it went
through as previously the ccg went
through the appropriate governance
process to formally get agreement to
reduce those Cycles down so it was just
to give give some Assurance about um any
queries in relation to the Trafford
cycle numbers thank you happy to take
questions well health watch yeah
um I think
IED on
ofal
twice and the first occasion was around
IVF and it was around the reduction in
Cycles uh the only um good thing in this
I can see in the
H um is that um GM is going to look at
some sort of rationalization about the
number of Cycles which I think has to be
so for example side has three we've got
one the other thing that um I might
missed it and I'm sure that you you can
correct me if I'm wrong but what it
doesn't do is tell me what the success
rate is um and I think that that's
absolutely crucial when we're talking
about investing money in this but I just
think that you know women go through so
much and it's interesting about the
women's hope I think that may well pick
up on on issues like this um and uh um
we would uh hope that
perhaps based on the evidence of
Effectiveness that GM will um consider
improving on the one
cycle thank you would you want to
respond to
that no thank you heather no I think
Heather's cover everything thank you any
further question oh Council Gilbert
please
yeah um so thanks for this it was um
really good to see it come through and I
welcome any kind of steps that reduce
the amount of admin that it takes for um
patients to be referred just want to
give a bit of context behind it I spent
14 years trying to conceive um my
children and my IVF baby is six next
week so I've been through this process
and I've got a lot of lived experience
in it um it affects one in six people
and it's uh I know we talk about women
but actually I think the figures
depending on what report you read it
there is male cause between 40 and 50%
of the time um as well a report by
fertility Network UK recently showed
that 40% of people going through this
process experience suicidal thoughts and
it has a huge impact on on mental health
and you know I can vouch for that it's a
very very stressful and upsetting
process that report also showed that
with the current cost of living crisis
49% of people can't afford private
treatment um and well I I can assume
that you would absolutely love to follow
the nice guidelines and offer three
cycles and you know I know that that
that first cycle it's often quite
exploratory because you're kind of
administering the drugs to stimulate the
follicles and create the eggs and every
woman's different so it's you know
they're kind of amending it as they go
along and that's quite often why when
you go to second and third Cycles
they're more successful because the
consultant has learned more about you
and can tailor that's that kind of
treatment more so that's another kind of
you know that really hurts to see it's
only one cycle because all those
learning's just gone unless you've got
the money and are able um to go
privately um so I guess my question is
in the light of that is what what will
it take for Trafford to get the three
Cycles as recommended by nice and I know
the answer's money but what what else
what how often are you revisiting this
decision at the moment as it indicates
in the report we don't have an intention
to revisit the number of Cycles for
Trafford specifically what we will be
doing is working with our GM um
colleagues across all localities to get
that standardization of IVF Cycles
across greater Manchester because we
believe that it's almost like at the
moment it's a postcode Lottery
completely understand how sensitive and
delicate this issue is I'm sure most
people have either know somebody or
experience themselves these issues so
it's really important that we get that
consistency of approach um as I'm sure
you probably know I know you've made
reference to money we have to consider
the complete entirety of everything that
we support in Trafford and it's not just
the number of ibf Cycles there are a
number of as I've just as discussed
around the table today there's so many
different competing priorities ities so
therefore I think um it's our position
at the moment that we will be working
with GM Partners to look at consistency
of approach of the number of ibf cycles
and we will be obviously supported of
what that looks like in the future when
they get to a conclusion um can you keep
us posted of course because like Heather
said I would look for um that my fear is
that everybody else will be leveled down
to the Trafford level um and obviously
what i' I'd love to see is that is that
go up and I've got a bit a plea um and I
don't know if you can pass this on to
the right colleagues but it's about it's
about information so um it's just not
easily accessible so if you and it never
has been in this area so if you get used
to Google ccg Trafford IVF you'd get
some policy from you know God knows when
and it's the same now and it's not that
service is not visible on the ICB um
noted website and that that is that is
information is so important complely
when you are working with your own
fertility and you know not everybody has
a great relationship with their GP so
just having that front and center and
really clear for Trafford residents
would be a massive massive win um for me
yeah certainly I put that up thank you
Council Slater I think the work that's
going on in GM around Women's Health and
um we that will be picked up and I think
that you know I for one who will be
sitting on the um the care partnership
board I will be advocating for Trafford
women to say that we should be in line
with others and and and I wouldn't want
to see a leveling down for anybody who
is receiving that treatment and the
point that you make about um accessible
language that is something that the ICB
is picking up isn't it around the lots
of reports and stuff that are going
online now that will be easy read
versions of all those reports so that
everybody can access it because it's
something that I AR on around all the
time we write for middle class 15 year
olds and actually at the reading age is
between five and 9 across GM and we need
to be making sure that everybody has the
same access so I'll be making sure that
I pick those things up at every
opportunity that I get um going forward
so thank
you Council Lester thank
you yeah I think I'd like to Echo as
well and I think probably everybody
would what we don't want to see as a
leveling down uh one of the things I'd
like to ask is is how Tam sides
achieving those three Cycles as in what
is there something that they're doing
that is good in t sides that we could
all be learning from some either
efficiencies or some way of working that
actually might mean that without a huge
amount of additional um investment which
we know that we know that finances are
tied um that we could you know find a
way to move upwards so yeah I'd be
interested to know what T side's doing
right really this
I don't know how to answer that no it's
really impossible to answer that because
this is one part of the ccg as was in
tamide you know as Kathy said there's
A's a whole mix of commissioned health
services so so it might be the case at
tamide commission less of another
service and being prioritized um the IVF
so so I don't I mean we can't answer
that question I think I think the focus
now is now we're one organization not 10
organizations so to do that
standardization piece across all 10 and
that's I think the important thing
moving
forward
CC pick up everybody's
it's increasing so even if we two cycles
it would be certainly better when we'
got the time for all the reasons that
we've just discussed it's really
important to
wom um yeah you not just women I would
say
my um I'd just like to Echo councilor
Gilbert's uh comments about information
and about pling English for a lot of
stuff a lot of people want to know
success rates a lot of people want to
know um you how it what are the effects
going to be um
I a lot of people don't see and I don't
claim to know a lot about this area as
well but a lot of people don't realize
there can be a Kickstart consequence to
two failed IVs IVF
Cycles um and it would be it would be
really interesting to actually have
those figures especially when we're
talking about how we're going to
standardize across GM I would advocate
for two across the board um simply
because there is a Kickstart consequence
and we know women that have had two
failed cycles and then gone on to
conceive naturally uh and not just once
but twice and three times and it's just
having that followup figure to actually
say to women look this may not work but
you may find you are part of that group
um and it just gives that little bit of
Hope um moving forward for a lot of
people thank you can I just come back on
that just really quickly um when GM do
their review they will be going through
a complete quality impact assessment and
E equality impact assessment as well and
all the data that you're describing will
be part of that review because they have
to use all that to base it to get the
evidence based to be able to make a
decision on what is best so just to give
some assurance that that will be and
comm's taking note Absolutely I'll make
sure it's done thank you C later and I
think a lot of the work that's going on
in GM is um it's B it's based on lived
experience and that they've taken the
hearing resident stories and that's what
they're making decisions on so you know
nobody can take away what um councelor
Gilbert has shared with us this evening
she has a lived experience of of that
that system and one cycle doesn't mean
you know what it wasn't good and it's
not good enough for most people because
it's not it's like you said it's
exploratory it's not going to be the
actual implantation of that uh new baby
for you and stuff like that so I think
those lived experiences have got to form
the decision making around on this
process the same as we're doing with
mental health the same we're doing with
other things this needs to be a lived
experience LED um
review thank you for that um Council
Axford um yeah I'm aware that
infertility is incre increasing and I
just I'd like some more information
really I think we've kind of already
covered it about information about how
many women in in traford are receiving
treatment and the outcomes of that I
think it' be really useful to have that
information thank you
[Music]
thank you uh yeah so we'll get to a
further ongoing report on that from the
board that' be great and thank you for
the contribution from the member you
know the experience sort of give
everything a bit of context there in
terms of the work that is involved thank
you uh for good report can we approve
that
exactly was the question chair so so I'm
aware that a motion went to council last
week um so so I think it was on the back
of that and the Press interest so so all
I would say is that you we've talked
about the full review that we we've done
here I think probably three or four
times haven't we so just to give an
update where we are with that so so you
know we now have seven work streams
working through the findings from all of
the work we did with the residents
across Trafford you know lots of Rich
intelligence seven work streams one of
which was a minor injuries unit and the
future for that and I think we've talked
about those work streams before so in
terms of next steps that we're expecting
the findings or outputs from those work
streams and the recommendations and they
plan to go to the locality board in
December through that meetings on the
19th of December so what we're also
offering is another session for for
scrutiny members I don't think the
invites come out yet but it's planned
for Tuesday evening for anyone who's got
a real interest in this to have a
conversation to talk through the work of
the work streams and just a bit more of
the findings not the recommendations
because that report isn't available yet
but to work talk through the work we're
doing and in the same way that we have
with lots of different groups across
Trafford you know over the last few
months so so that's all I was going to
update no decisions have been made at
this point I think is the is the last
thing I say but that
offer that would be very useful that in
interaction yeah okay thank you C it was
just about dates I think there was a
confusion because when you last gave the
update I think we were all thinking oh
it'll be the end of October when we'll
get that feedback but you've given the
date the 19th of December to the
locality board so it will come back to
us in
January is that what we're
saying we are we actually having just an
extra meeting before Christmas yeah this
will be the extra meeting this so
recommendations from the seven work
streams are going to the locality board
on the 19 I've offered a further chance
to discuss this as an extraordinary um
informal meeting with scrutiny members
on Tuesday evening and that is going to
come around um well today or tomorrow um
and then and then following the decision
made if a decision is in fact made at
the locality board then we will follow
due process or whatever that decision
is so youe to report inch as a
final that you said there is an extra
day say CH that be online yes it is
online you know that's not to talk about
the decision that's to talk through the
findings of the work we've done in the
review
suban and then after you got to Bo maybe
we can just go to January rather than
March yeah you know it's up to you you
know we will have been to the locality
board so we can provide a further update
in January if that's what the committee
was
C
heartley thank you chair yeah I I think
um the concern of the committee is
probably just to be cited on I
appreciate the recommendations out
available yet but to be cited on those
recommendations before a decision is
made so um so I think the offer of an
extra session is is really useful and I
think it's a good idea but I guess maybe
my question is just about the process in
the governance is is that if it goes to
the locality board on 19th of December
what is that for is that to note the
recommendations or is that to make any
decision I think that's probably the
anxiety that the committee have thank
you so so locality board is to make a
decision on the recommendations what we
will do at the Tuesday session it's not
Tau through the recommendation but but
to talk through the options and then
we'll be able to provide that feedback
in the report that goes to locality
Board of what the feedback from scrutiny
was on the options and we've got that
sort of intelligence from previous
discussions anyway I think I I could
probably say that now but um so that's
the process and the governance that
we're
planning can I just ask um are those
papers for the locality board are they
published a week
before yes yes we a for seven working
days so in2 we might by abely so we'd
know a week before what the options are
that are going to ality board and then
on the
19th there could be a decision yes yes
the papers are publicized on the
icbs
righte we are for the
get yes you will see the option yeah if
you having a meeting on Tuesday I won't
be able to come I think quite a few of
our members won't be able to come
because there already meeting um in in
the diary um and also
um going through the options is great
but it will be published anyway sort of
a a week or so couple of weeks no a week
afterwards I think what G suggesting is
that have the meeting with yourselves
take feedback from yourself that
feedback will then be taken to locality
board who will make the decision with
your feedback yeah I know but if a lot
of us can't come then Tuesday is not
available if you tell us if we days with
Stephanie May you know we've done that
on the availability of people are going
to be giving the information if that but
we already have given you the
information haven't we in in since
you've been here yeah well we just
wanted to offer another opportunity to
have a dedicated scrutiny session with
members so that you could have
one-on-one discussions with the team
who've been part of the review just as
any a clarification points just to give
an extra opportunity really um would you
be able to give us some updates that you
could do or or can we s come up with uh
some
options I think sorry I don't understand
what not sure for for the for the
date when you meet you you able to
options yeah yeah it's just arrange the
date so yeah sorry CH I I I
think I mean we have we have looked at
um a lot of about this rightly so we've
we've had views about it and uh in terms
of the work streams that are going on I
think we've had all that information
before so I think you know we can look
back at those reports if we need to I
think um but I think in order for us to
give meaningful input before the
locality board make a decision we need
to see the papers for that locality
board so I think if we are going to have
another meeting I'd say it be best to do
it between the 12th and the 19th because
um it's a significant decision
and we can talk about powers of calling
and all that sort of stuff but if we
want to give input before that decision
it's got to be meaningful input and I
don't think we will be able to give that
on Tuesday I think we'll be able to give
that once the papers are out appreciate
that's a short time scale but if if the
papers are only available a week before
the meeting that's the best we can do
um but I but I do feel we should sorry
CH so that would mean any feedback from
scrutiny wouldn't be included in a paper
going to the locality board so what we
were trying to do was talk through talk
through the options and then have that
clear feedback and then build that into
a report that was going so that will
include the feedback from the other
stakeholder groups that we've had it
would also include the feedback that
we've had from from yourselves um you
know I'm not wedded to that approach if
you think there's a merit in I think
you're right in a way because I mean
whatever we say then perhaps There's an
opportunity to feed it into the locality
board isn't there and yeah I'm sorry I
just wanted to just to clarify again so
we wouldn't be
discussing the the only bit you've not
seen is the proposed recommendation of
what we recommend based on the
information we we collectively want your
views on what the review is telling us
to so when you look at that 171 page
document all that data and all that
intelligence what what does that look
like and obviously we've fed back about
what the patient engagement um sorry
public engagement has looked like in
regards to what that review is telling
us as well so it there wouldn't be
anything different than probably like
what you've said what what you've
already seen the only element that would
be different is the recommendation
element that you obviously have not been
seen at this at this
point C I think part of the problem is
that we we're all held
accountable and the locality board you
know everyone that I knock on the door
and then means fully respect don't know
what that locality board does right they
don't understand it so either I have to
explain to everyone that you've made the
decision or we can point to ourselves as
health scrutiny and say this was our
recommendation to that local uh board
locality board this is what health
scrutiny of Trafford Council wants to do
wants to happen if you
disagree okay but we have something on
record say this was our
recommendation and what we want to
happen AC you know and across all seven
actually CU but um in particular as
obviously last week showed the
contentious issue is that um old
altering and minor in unit and what
happens to it in particular sorry I'm
just I think I've got where we're up to
I
know so so we have done a lot of work
with residents of Trafford so it's not
just you and we've been having those
conversations we've spent hours and
hours as a team to do that and all the
way from the survey to going through all
of the results in detail with with a
number of groups so so we have you I'm
not too happy saying that it's only you
having the conversation with the public
because we have made a huge effort to do
that secondly in terms of your
recommendation if you want to feed to us
what your recommendation would be then
we would happily put that in the report
to say yeah and the over helming view
from or from these councilors was this
then then that's fine and that's what we
were trying to do on Tuesday evening but
it
have be
really what trying to say is they don't
feel comfortable with going ahead
without having seen the recommendation
forward on their behalf so I'm saying if
the papers are ready sort of a week in
advance of the 19th so say 11 12 is
there a way we can have the on the 8th
of December so then you will be able to
include the feedback from members and I
because if they're ready on the 12
possibly sort of radio as close out on
the 8 as a as a possible dat just a few
days ear so members would have a chance
to go through those recommendation and
say yes no whatever and then you could
include that now so so happy to have a
conversation on the 8th I haven't looked
in I haven't looked in my calendar I
mean that might be a Sunday I don't know
but
still happy to do it so so so when
pardon that's Friday so I'd be happy to
have a conversation with you on the
Friday but the results you the
recommendations won't be published until
the 12th so happy to have the
conversation and then you can feed your
comments and your recommendations and we
will ensure that that Finds Its weth to
its way to the locality
World personally I think this is far to
short notice for us as a scrutiny
committee to make a
recommendation um because we normally
have it published um
because because of the accountability
and all of a sudden we're now sort
saying oh we could you can feed in and
but you've got to do it by by this
week and I don't know about anybody else
but my diary is actually um full and I
just think if we had that power we
should have known that
some time ago because we could have had
an extra meeting or we could have
discussed it this meeting um and and
actually made those recommendations to
feed into that I think we have made it
well I think we're GNA have to discuss
it tonight or we can't do
[Music]
it yeah yeah yeah just to come back so
so I think that we have brought this on
a number of occasions so I think we have
made a conscious effort to include
scrutiny throughout the whole of the
process for the last year and a half so
I don't necessarily agree with what You'
just said councelor but I I understand
time scales from now until the 19th are
short and what we were trying to do on
Tuesday or another day is to give you
another
opportunity just to make sure you had
that final say and if you don't want
well then have you you've you've taken
the views of us because you've been here
more than once
is there a way um that we can
collect um those
views
um I
thinka wait yeah we can do it by
email sorry I'm confused no
um I suppose it's knowing what you're
going to say to a certain
extent um so that we've
got view of it I mean there is Merit in
being uh meet in meeting uh and getting
that beforehand
OB any extra meeting is always going to
be more beneficial rather than having no
meeting
um so I'm just thinking what is it is
it from from a governance point of view
I mean what council Lloyd is saying do
you think that it's valid
umid
[Music]
disagree change you
need and then is
T just a few days you TW
littleit
MERS yeah come back on that yeah so I'm
afraid I totally disagree from a
Governor's perspective you know we can't
share the recommendations ahead of
sharing them with the for the locality
board previously what we have done in
detail is talked through what the
options could be for the minor injuries
unit so we talk through changing that on
a number of ways what that might look
like in the future so I think the
committee's had the opportunity to do
that and I think I I've probably got a
strong view of what that would be so so
if you want to clate your views based on
the previous conversations and let us
have those then more than happy to feed
that into the report that goes to
locality board and is published on the
12th
ler um I just wanted to understand what
happens after that after that it's gone
to the locality board on the 19th
because if if a decision's made is that
then that's the decision made or is that
a pro a part of the process and actually
from there then there will be further
consultation so that's not actually
that's not the final
step that's a really good point so if
the recommendation and the decision that
the locality board is for a significant
service change as you know then there
would be a formal engagement and
consultation process to go through which
would last a number of months and then
you we would have obviously further
opportunity to discuss that here so if
we as a scrutiny whatever was decided on
the 19th if we as a scrutiny group
strongly disagreed for whatever
reason the there's still an opportunity
going forward to put further to further
influence
it is that right yes it' be taken into
account in the consultation it'll be one
part of the wider consultation with the
whole of the Trafford
population
decision think that's that's a process
that we would end up going into if it's
whatever's agreed on that day people
don't like that decision then that
consultation well that consultation will
start whatever happen consultation will
start on aspects of
the right Council Taylor I think um
thank you for the offer of the meeting
on the 7th but I think it's looking
unlikely that many of us will be able to
join you for that is it possible to have
site of a draft of these papers before
they are in the public domain before
they're publicized on the 12th so we can
at least have sight of them and maybe
comment and our comments could be
recorded within those papers before they
are publicized so when it comes to
locality board there is that awareness
and that record that we have had sight
of those and that we've we've commented
I know we've had numerous discussions
about it and I'm sure you've got a
strong sense of probably our thoughts
about it but could we have sight of
those and then you know it's placed on
record that we have contributed and our
thoughts about this are within those
papers I thought if there was going to
be a significant change to
service then you there's supposed to be
a discussion with the chair of
scrutiny
beforehand
so that's my understanding of how SC me
works if I'm wrong somebody correct
me yeah so so what's what's your
position on this then in in that regard
so so I'll say again we have taken this
through scrutiny three or four times
including the possible outcomes for a
range of options including the minor
injuries unit so I think we' fulfill
that Duty from a government's
perspective councelor Taylor's question
I'll take that back I don't think that
would fit in with with the normal
governance but but I will you do some
looking into that and if it's possible
to do it's not that we're trying to hide
something I'm really I'm that's you know
quite the opposite if it's possible to
share it as a draft I'm happy to do that
I I just don't think that that would be
in line with normal governments to share
a paper going to the locality
board prior to can I just ask how the
chair we've got the chair here so uh hav
got the chair here oh no sorry
okay okay that's
Council as an alternative to what
councel Taylor suggests is is there not
a process for addendums to be submitted
for that meeting so late papers so the
papers get published as normal but we
can have a look and provide comments and
then that features in a an
addendum yeah i' be very comfortable
with the papers are published on 12 if
something came from scrutiny to say
these are our thoughts on the proposal I
happy to for that to be included
discussion that could work
then yeah thank you for that yeah think
that okay so we agree that as a
committee then yeah yeah um so locality
board will meet on the 19th and make a
decision and then I I would probably ask
chair if we can probably see not
necessarily have people in we don't as
you said you've explained it you've been
to meetings but we need to have sight of
that on the January the 17th meeting to
actually discuss it and make our
final
yeah
yeah but then our
response
consult and do we give a response in
January or after you know after it
yeah yeah that's
fine all
right
so you you know in the uh to do them so
what I'm expecting is we'll publish as
planned on the 12th yeah and then
between the 12th and the 19th then we
will receive something from scrutiny
with comments on the papers that were
published on the 12 yeah okay is that St
me y do it be helpful as well Shar if it
can be clear if they are the thoughts of
the committee in total or of certain
individual counselors I think it'd be
really helpful if we had that that might
change you know how that's you know how
that land
might absolutely
yeah yeah certainly I mean thing is it's
an important subject in the topic so I
think that collectively yeah may I
suggest then once we have sight of those
papers could we as a committee maybe
have a an extraordinary meeting maybe
even if it's just a teams meeting or you
know an online meeting to yeah to
discuss that and then you know the views
expressed represent and reflect those of
all of us yeah committee I think that's
and and we are allowed to vote actually
in scrutiny so sorry Judy say second you
you you can have a vote in scrutiny you
don't normally you normally come to a
consensus but if the words came to the
worst um we would have to look at that
but there are rules about scrutiny and
they they're published on the website it
might this might be an opportunity to um
update ourselves
right so we agree that action
as said okay approve that thank
you
so that that was tough on
it